The joe rogan experience podcast comes at you again.
Oh,
with,
uh,
with laptop on old school.
Old School.
Retard moves.
That's me.
Fuckers.
I can't get it right.
Ever.
We're brought to you by several things,
but before we even get to that,
um,
we got Brian and um,
Thompson Gaura and Tony Hinchcliffe has some fucking shows coming up in Ohio
that are awesome.
Uh,
one of them sold out already.
The Columbus one is sold out,
right?
Yeah.
The first show of Columbia sold out.
Second one is almost sold out.
And then there's your also doing date,
Dayton,
Ohio,
Thursday and then Cincinnati Friday.
And we decided to put out a ticket,
a coupon code there that will give you two for one tickets.
It's Red Cross and 10% of the proceeds go to hurricane relief for,
it's beautiful for Florida.
That's beautiful.
And a on top of that,
you will,
it's not floor.
Would that be fucked up if it's like,
yeah,
we're collecting hurricane money and we're,
it's going to send it to Texas.
Yeah.
There's a couple of people that lost their fences.
How far did it go in?
Eh,
it went in pretty deep.
I know Ohio got jacked by it,
but it started up north,
right?
Yeah.
Started up to super annoying.
We'll start.
It was in the Caribbean though,
but then when it touched down in America,
touchdown North Jersey,
it killed so many people in the Caribbean and we don't even paying attention to
that about the superstorm.
They're going to get Wednesday.
Yeah,
they're getting a superstorm Wednesday.
That's supposedly,
it's going to have winds up to 65 miles per hour.
That's just going to hit New York again and so it's going to just fuck
everything up again.
Oh my God.
Fuck that man.
Fuck living on the east coast.
Yeah.
Fuck all that hurricane nonsense.
That stuff's nuts for tickets.
Oh good.
It does.
Quad that TV or a brown paper.
tickets.com and search for a deck squat and another show news.
I'm at the Balboa theatre this Saturday night in San Diego with a Joey Diaz,
Aka mad flavor.
So are you coming?
What are you doing?
Uh,
what Thursday?
No Saturday sat around.
I'm in Columbus,
Ohio.
This same date.
Okay.
So if you're on the west coast folks and trying to stay alive,
not freeze,
you'd tick off.
Yeah.
Bow,
bullet theater,
San Diego,
Columbus,
Ohio,
Dayton and Cincinnati with Brian,
who's fucking killing it lately.
Brian killed it this weekend in San Francisco and killed it in Seattle.
Even better,
man.
It was,
you're really getting funny,
man.
It's,
it's fun to watch,
fun to watch you add new shit and growing and stuff.
Well,
you gave me great advice.
Just be more silly.
And so I,
I've yourself,
yeah,
I'm just being,
it's hard trying to be yourself 100%.
You're almost like,
I just want to get through this joke and make it perfect.
Instead of just being like Utah telling a friend at joke or something.
Yeah.
You're getting to be,
you're just getting more comfortable on stage.
They already like you.
So it's,
it's a different sort of a scenario you're learning.
Stand up in front of a bunch of people who already like you,
which is a huge,
huge advantage.
But a,
the crowds are awesome.
So thanks.
Uh,
San Francisco,
people in Seattle,
people was fucking awesome.
We had,
we had an amazing weekend.
Greg Fitzsimmons crushed it.
So funny.
Oh,
he's hilarious.
He's much funnier.
Even then.
I've seen him lately.
I mean he's always been great,
but he was like,
he was on fire this weekend and it was like the perfect kind of crowd for him.
They were all savages.
Um,
so thanks for that.
Before we even get into any commercials,
look at this real quick.
Yeah.
This is from the,
just to show you,
you're going on stage.
This is in San Francisco.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
bizarre.
Soon we will start to cope,
but not yet.
The job experiences buzzard by Ting Ting,
ting,
ting is that felt cope with just sitting here going,
what the fuck did I get myself into?
Man,
I was hoping I was just going to go here and promote my awesome book.
I got to deal with these assholes.
That nonsense.
Ting is a,
uh,
it's a cell phone company that uses the backbone of sprint.
It is an excellent cell phone company.
What they're doing is they're giving you the same service as far as like your
reception and everything that you would get with a major provider.
But they're doing it in a very,
in what I believe are very ethical and fair way.
They're there,
first of all,
they're offering their service with no contracts.
You don't have to have a contract that you have to cancel and pay a bunch of
fucking money back for that.
That shit's gross.
That you got to pay them to get out of your cell phone contract.
That's ridiculous.
That's a competition issue.
That's all that is.
I mean,
could you,
uh,
could you imagine if that was the case for any other service?
Like if you every wanted to get a,
a gallon of milk,
you had to continue to give these people money and buy their milk.
Or if you didn't do that,
you would have to pay them because you're not going to buy their milk anymore
and be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Guess what?
Cause the same thing with a cell phone company.
It's nuts.
We're just,
we just accepted this silly stupid fucking way and the way they get away with
it,
as they trick you into thinking you're paying less for a phone than you are,
so they sorta like roll the money that you would have spent if you bought the
phone for full price.
They sort of roll that into your bill and that's how they justify giving you a a
cancellation fee.
But really what it is is it's like a way of strong arming you in sticking
around.
They got your bitch.
You don't want to give up that 300 bucks.
Well that's not the case with Ting and with tin there.
They're there.
So Fair.
In fact that if you only like,
say there's,
there's different tiered programs,
but if you use one program you will use like half the minutes you thought you
did well,
they discount you on the next month.
I mean it's like the coolest setup you could ever hope for.
They have awesome devices.
If you go to rogan.ting.com they have it set up so that you say 50 bucks off
your first
Tang device.
You just click that link and check out all the different devices they have.
They have top of the line android phones.
I have the Samsung Galaxy s three.
That's the only one that I can talk about that I've actually used personally.
It's the only one I've actually used since the,
I had an old droid and there was a piece of shit.
It was terrible.
It had like a,
it's like a keyboard.
It was wack.
But this thing is Badass.
This is a very,
very good
I've had is I noticed in Seattle,
everyone had that phone.
I saw that more than iPhone.
It's a killer phone.
It's,
there's no denying it.
That thing's the shit.
And uh,
it's um,
it's legit.
Like there's,
there's been some phones in the past where people are good.
You know,
this,
my windows phones just as good as your iPhone.
Ah,
no,
it's not,
it's just not,
the android is the first time I've ever seen a real solid argument for it
actually being better.
It has a way bigger screen.
The screen is amazing.
The galaxy STD screen,
it's incredible that the pictures are beautiful.
It's way better for doing like online shit.
If you want to like go online and check out websites,
there's no denying that that bigger screen is fucking way better.
It's just better,
you know?
So then it comes down to texting and phone calls and it's great at those.
So what else do you need?
You know when it gets,
I'm seriously thinking about not using iPhones anymore,
especially with all this,
this concept.
I'm not kidding.
This is nonsense with the fucking maps,
you know,
and the one guy quit because he didn't want to apologize for maps and they took
youtube off the like,
you don't just automatically get youtube,
you got to go get it as an APP.
No,
it is a,
it's a nicer app and the Google maps APP is going to be out any day now.
So that's going to be better.
And once that happens,
then I,
yeah,
it's back to normal.
But I'm telling you need to
get ahold of Ting Tang.
If you're listening,
we need to get Brian a Samsung galaxy s three because,
well,
how come I've never figured this out.
Why?
How can we talk about this in the beginning of every podcast?
I don't get you a fucking phone.
Fuck,
I'm,
I know no show is this.
No,
no,
no.
You'd break it down immediately,
but I did with the iPad this week while you do it with everything,
you were fucking,
you're weird.
You're weird.
There were dude,
really love it.
Uh,
but look,
I,
I firmly endorsed Tang.
It's fucking bad ass company.
Um,
you can get,
you could split a plan and he's like,
you can split the minutes with your girlfriend or your wife or your,
your buddy,
what do whatever you want to do.
Um,
there's a lot of different flexible options.
It's a,
it's just an excellent company and that's the only things that will,
we're ever gonna support on this podcast,
whether it's an audible.com or on it.com or anything we support.
We are 100% in a supporting ethical companies that are cool,
that sell products that we believe in.
That's really it.
You know when,
when we sell Alpha brain and we sell shroom tech sport or any of the products
from on it,
I use all that shit.
I've used all that shit way before I ever had any sort of a,
a business connection to it.
I,
I've always been a fan of,
uh,
first of all healthy food.
I mean,
that's just like a Duh,
you have to say that,
but it is something that's super important to constantly reinforce.
The more nutrients you take in your body,
the better your body works.
The more water you drink,
I'm not saying only eat perfect.
I will fuck off and have chocolate cake.
I,
um,
I like to have a diet coke.
Every now and again I'll give myself like one or two diet cokes a week.
You know,
it's not,
it's not eliminate all this shit from your diet,
but if you have a diet that is rich in nutrients,
especially phytonutrients,
plant nutrients,
like a strong stuff like Kale and spinach,
it's just better for your fucking life,
man.
It's just better taking nutrients,
taking vitamins like Alpha brain,
which is a cognitive enhancing supplement formula.
The idea is that we've taken all the best food and nutrients,
all the ingredients that enhance cognitive function and put it into a vitamin
form.
The key with all the products that on it,
one of the big keys is there's 100% money back guarantee without even returning
the product.
If you buy off a brain and you try it and he didn't do shit for me,
just you get your money back.
It's not,
there's no questions asked.
So it's not like we want you to send the pills back and throw them up or
something.
No one's trying to rip you off.
We're selling you things that I 100% believe in that I use,
that I've had definite positive benefits from.
And uh,
we,
we want it to be a positive experience for everybody that orders.
So if you,
you know,
if you,
if you order it,
we want you to order more because you enjoy it and because it benefits you and
if it didn't benefit you,
it wouldn't be something that we'd sell or were,
were not interesting.
The,
the,
the fitness equipment that we sell is all shit that I use.
Kettle bells,
especially huge proponent of kettlebells,
you know,
between Kettlebells,
bodyweight squats and Chin ups.
You can get fucking ferocious workouts and like unbelievable heart exploding,
ferocious workouts.
The idea that,
you know,
you need a bunch of different equipment to get an incredible full body workout.
It's really a myth.
You,
you need,
uh,
I believe you need a couple of different weights of kettle bells and a chin up
bar and you can get almost anything done.
There's so many different options as far as exercises.
There's a million free videos that you can get online,
off youtube and watched of various workouts that people put together.
Just,
just put cattle bells,
just throw that shit in a youtube and you'll find it.
And,
uh,
we,
we also have an accumulating supply of different things that are too to enhance
health and different things that are to enhance physical reform,
performance,
mental performance.
We were trying to stay on the edge of everything that we hear about that has any
benefit.
It's one of the reasons we're going to start caring.
Um,
uh,
Dave Asprey's MCT oil when it,
sell it through on it as well.
And his,
uh,
his coffee,
he's a,
he's got a amazing coffee and amazing theories on coffee and why a lot of us
feel sick when you drink it.
You don't realize that there's actually toxic mold and a large percentage of the
coffee that's sold in America.
Dave Aspery is a fucking brilliant guy and having him on the podcast was so
eyeopening
when it came to how food is stored,
mold and fungus as that can grow on food.
How important is to avoid that?
How much mold and fungus grows on corn or crazy?
So we're going to try to start carrying his stuff as well,
just because it's the vast,
and he had this buffalo and Mary Barra easy.
Yeah.
We,
we started carrying these to a bars or a tonka bars rather tonka was,
that's what I used to call the buffalo.
It's what he's call me.
Kat Tonka.
Um,
they're,
they're amazing.
They're made with cranberries and buffaloes and it's a,
it's buffalo jerky and super healthy,
super lean and a,
you get to feel like you're Davy Crockett and shit like you went out and at a
buffalo we can eat buffalo again for while we couldn't eat him.
I'm saying pick drunken dangerous.
Really.
I think so.
Let's get them back on that list guys.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and it get yourself some Alpha brain.
Oh,
if you use the code name rogue and you'll save 10% off of any and all
supplements,
Alpha brain,
shroom,
tech,
sport,
new mood,
you name it,
chuck it all out.
And we also have,
well there's plenty of shit.
I can't even fit it all in a car commercial because it'll get too annoying.
But go go there on it.
O n n I t and the code works only for supplements.
10% off.
All right folks,
Philip Copans is here.
Am I pronouncing it correctly,
sir?
Well,
close enough.
And,
uh,
we're,
we're fixing it busy.
I'm going to talk about ancient civilizations,
ladies and gentlemen,
my personal favorite subject of all time,
the Joe Rogan experience,
train by day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Powerful.
Phillip Copans.
How are you sir?
I'm doing good.
That's a long dragged out ending.
Uh,
thanks for coming man.
And uh,
you're,
you're here about your book.
Your book is,
uh,
the lost civilization enigma and uh,
this,
uh,
I,
I got into this subject through Graham Hancock who I'm sure you're familiar
with,
his work,
um,
the fingerprints of the gods.
I before that I had no idea that there were so many mysteries in,
in terms of like how ancient structures were constructed,
you know,
who the people were that actually designed them and built them.
And it,
it's an amazing part of the history of the human race that is,
um,
really doesn't get enough attention in my opinion.
And I don't understand why.
Well,
I think we've somehow kind of like,
you know,
we have this 4,000 BC Wallander and anything before that people just don't seem
to be interested in and it doesn't get into textbooks.
It doesn't get into official kind of anything.
And anything before that is just treated as if it's sporadic.
We've been around for 35,000 years and we were led to believe that for 30,000
years of Dell existence,
we did nothing.
We sat on our bum.
Is it because of the fact that the information wasn't available when the people
who are professors right now we're teaching and they would teach you for 20 and
30 years,
some of them and they don't want to like rewrite what they have already taught.
Like it's,
there's an ego thing to it that would you've,
they've taught you that,
you know,
this was built in 2000
BC and that's,
that's where it ends.
Absolutely.
I mean,
there's one example in the book in the opening chapter is called the new
inquisition and it's about one,
several cases,
but one of them is from the 1920s and basically in the 1920s at discovery was
made in France glozell and if this was true,
early indications were that writing was thousands of years older than everybody
had been writing about all of these professors who are going to be proven wrong
and they just couldn't let that happen.
So what they did was he had a 16 year old farmer boy who just found a hole in
his field who said like,
Hey,
look what I have found.
Um,
and they threw him in jail and they pretended that he was thrown in jail for
fraud.
And ever after science could say like,
well,
he was arrested on fraud,
wasn't he?
We don't have to look at this guy because he was arrested on fraud and he was
completely vindicated.
There was no evidence whatsoever that he had made fraudulent claims about the
artifacts which he'd found.
But ever since the 1920s according to the eyelids,
free walls of academics,
this is a complete thing which they don't have to look into anymore because they
have labeled it a fraud.
Wow.
So you think there was a conspiracy to label it a fraud and Hema fraud just so
that they didn't have to address it?
Yes.
Why?
How is that possible?
Isn't it weird that academics are supposed to be the leading lights of thought?
They're supposed to be the people that are at the forefront of knowledge,
but for the most part they are.
For the most part they are,
but there are exceptions and there are issues.
The the Egyptologists that you know,
that guy who was a arguing with a Robert Schoch and Graham Hancock in that fee
or in a John Anthony West and that famous video where they're dealing with this
obvious water erosion on the stones and all these geologists are saying like,
you've got a problem here because this was cut at like 9,000 plus BC.
There's no other way around it.
If you look at climate change,
you look at that,
it had to be thousands of years of rainfall to create these erosions.
And the way he reacted was so egotistical and nonscientific it was really
infuriating.
He was laughing like what evidence of the civilization from 10,000 years ago do
you have?
And it was so infuriating to see a guy who's supposed to be uh,
the,
the man out there at the forefront of knowledge when it comes to this particular
subject.
He's a guy who,
a professor at a university,
a highly respected one and here he is,
he's carrying the flag for knowledge in this particular subject.
And he is,
if he could see how gross it looked to watch that reaction,
like why don't you tell me what the fuck you think would be around from 10,500
years ago,
dude,
cause I don't think it's going to be much.
I really don't think we barely can find shit from 2000 beers years ago.
We barely find shit from 2000 BC,
barely.
We finally a little pottery.
Oh,
we found some place where nobody got killed by mud.
Quick,
get over here.
Let's clean this shit with a,
with a paintbrush.
But you want to go more time back from that than it is from us to the
construction of the pyramids.
And it is from the established 2,500 BC,
which is insanity.
That's an insane amount of time.
And you're talking about 8,000 years before that you're supposed to know or have
any evidence whatsoever other than giant stones.
What the fuck do you think would be left,
right?
Yeah.
I mean the great doctors I was,
and just to kind of come back on the conspiracy angle there,
he,
in the 1980s had actually found evidence that the pyramids,
the Great Pyramid of Giza,
carbon dating results were in uncontested 800 years old.
Now that might not see much at 2,400 would make it 3,200 BC,
but it's 800 years.
It's,
it's basically long time man.
And they don't want to do it.
So what do they do for the last 30 years?
They haven't published these findings because for them to play the game,
it has to be published in a peer reviewed scientific journal,
and so by not publishing this,
they can pretend these carbon dating results don't exist and they can pretend
that everything is fine,
that the great perimeter is built in 2,400 BC.
They set the rules,
they played a game,
and then they shout at everybody else.
As you're pointing out one year,
Robert Schoch and everybody else comes to these things and say,
you're already,
it's
well,
it's clear to this ego involved,
which is very,
very disturbing when it comes to knowledge.
When it comes to something that is obviously a work in progress,
the uncovering of ancient civilizations is clearly a work in progress.
So to be arrogant about what the results are,
just based on the fact that you've taught these to students for so many years
and you don't want to admit that you were wrong when you're talking about the
the time,
the construction,
that's finks,
whatever it is that,
that,
that it is,
that starts getting controversial.
There's a weird thing where you see their ego flare up and it's so gross and
it's so transparent.
It's really weird to watch them argue like,
like little girls like the way they talk about it.
So Ego maniacal.
It's like what are you taught you?
What?
You know exactly what the fuck happened?
No you don't.
And you need to take this into consideration.
You've got a real issue because if this guy's right,
then you way off,
if this guy's right and this sphinx enclosure was cut 9,000 plus BC,
then you've got a real problem on your hands because you've,
you've established this whole timeline.
It doesn't work anymore because there was obviously some really,
so then we have to figure how,
what the fuck happened that we had this incredible sophistication at 10,000 BC
and then there's obviously spend some declines here and there.
This is a really obvious system.
If you,
if you really pay attention to like go Beckley,
tat bay or all of these really 14,000 plus BC things,
it's like this isn't like a s a linear graph.
It doesn't like go straight up.
There's like probably some fairly sophisticated cultures wiped out,
fairly sophisticated,
wiped out and other places.
Just like today you can go to Africa today and there's a lot of people that if
you didn't,
if Western civilization didn't go in there and give them things,
they wouldn't have radios.
They wouldn't be wearing underwear.
They would be living exactly the same way they with thousands and thousands of
years ago.
At the same time on other parts of the world,
people are dropping bombs on people,
people are doing nuclear tests,
people are,
you know,
they're doing the large Hadron collider that's all taking place at the exact
same time.
I suspect that's always been like that.
I suspect that there's been some super duper sophisticated cultures where for
whatever reason these people were ever able to figure out how to use agriculture
earlier,
figure out how to use societies and Wa figured out how to become enough to start
breaking things down and thinking it through and trying to figure out how to
improve things.
And then it's this exponential process in these groups and some of them get
better at it than others and it seems to be like,
it's like who wasn't attacked by hordes of barbarians.
You know,
those dudes seem to figure out how to,
you know,
get it.
Like all you need is like a couple of decades to get ahead.
If you look at like what we've accomplished in 100 years,
you know,
it's really staggering thing when that's the most staggering thing about whether
it's a ball back,
the stones in Lebanon or,
or Egypt or anything.
The most staggering thing is how far we've come in a hundred years and to think
that this shit was all going on thousands and thousands and thousands of years
ago.
Those numbers are just bullshit to us.
You start telling someone 7,000 years ago,
it's like Blah Blah.
I hear noise coming out of your mouth.
I really don't.
I can't see it.
I don't know what it means,
but I think it's the problem because the way history is still then it is like,
you know for 30,000 TSV sat on our,
but then we stood up and we scramble around for some food and then all of a
sudden in 4,000 BC somebody finds a light switch and all of a sudden it's
civilization.
That's the standard two and it doesn't work like that.
And then when you confront them with things like tobacco tap,
your cattle,
you work or anything like that,
they'll say,
well,
you know,
they were very close to like a few thousand people in a city somewhere who would
doing this.
But it was all isolated and it just doesn't work.
You know?
Great Empires exist.
Great Empires for our ancestors were saying about this as well.
They're basically saying about Atlantis,
you know this civilization existed.
Then it disappeared and are we kind of got it?
No,
no,
no.
Because we were sitting in the book sittings phase of civilization 10,002 years
ago.
Nobody was building anything.
Nobody was doing anything.
And it is just look,
because you can't argue with them.
They know for sure about how this was,
we were sitting on our butts for thousands of years.
Then we scrambled around a bit and then all of a sudden in 4,000 BC we finally
see the light and here we are.
And it is this very much like evolution of mankind taken to the absolute
extreme.
Hmm.
It's a,
it's a weird sort of cognitive denial.
It's very strange.
It's very strange that it's like,
it's,
it's like,
it's like laboring Labor,
uh,
labeling something,
a conspiracy theory.
Like,
Oh,
you a conspiracy theorist.
Like automatically or even how the new one is truther that's hilarious.
The nine one one people like truth nine,
one one truth.
They became truth hers like somehow or another it's an insult to be a truther.
That's,
that shit's for doing so.
Well.
I mean,
I was doing something for my blog,
which is going to be on somewhere in the next few days and it's about the
Kennedy assassination and the single bullet theory.
And the single bullet theory was invented by Arlen Specter,
who was a very junior lawyer at that time.
And he basically saw the Zapruder film,
which basically is a guy shooting a film of,
of Kennedy.
And they,
they thought that the Malika Kolkata,
which was what was using shocked rife,
you could fire it at intervals of 2.3 seconds.
And you see on this film how Kennedy reacts to a gunshot and commonly reacts to
a gunshot as well.
And the interval is less than 2.3 so all of a sudden they have this issue of
like,
oh,
there are two rifleman there,
or we need to try and explain it the way.
So comes in spec their junior lawyer who basically gets to solve this problem
and he comes up with a single bullet theory,
which basically says the shot goes into the back of Kennedy,
somehow travels up,
goes down,
jumps up again to go into Connally's back,
kind of like keeps traveling up a bit,
goes down again into his wrist and then up again.
And he calls it the magic bullet theory.
And when he goes public with this,
he basically says like,
I don't expect anybody to leave this shit and this is going to be contested in a
year,
five years,
a hundred years from now.
Nobody should believe that.
And guess what?
Academic history has taken this on wholesale,
wholesale and everybody who says,
but the magic bullet is teary is just crap.
They're labeled conspiracy nuts.
It's,
yeah,
it's not just crap.
It's like you're,
you're almost,
it's almost unexcusable to believe it.
It was invented because of the guy in the underpass.
We got hit with a ricochet.
They had to attribute,
that was another reason for it.
They had attribute a bullet to this one guy hitting a curb and it ricocheted him
and he had to go to the hospital.
So they knew that one of the bullets missed one of the bullets hit this curb.
And the bill,
what they found was in the Gurney of governor Connolly when they brought him to
the hospital.
So the idea is that this fucking bullet came out of this dude's body and like
perfect form was just laying around there.
No one ever noticed it.
Like he got shot and it was like in his pocket or something.
It went through his body and landed in his pocket and then fell out
conveniently.
Right where they were looking around.
See if there's any evidence.
Oh look,
we found the bullet that did all the damage.
It looks to me when I'm watching Zapruder film,
I've never heard anybody say this,
but there's a scene,
there's part
it part of it where it does look like,
I mean he does.
His head definitely goes back into the left,
but the spray looks like it's going forward.
I wonder if he was hit more than once by by you know,
different snipers at the same time.
I mean I wonder how many,
how many actual shots went into his body because they know that there was the
one that went through the front that they tried to disguise as a tracheotomy if
they know there was definitely an entry wound the neck and that's when he grabs
his neck.
Just that alone.
The fact that that was deceptively labeled as a tracheotomy whole,
why would you do that?
Why would you,
the only reason cause you don't want to show an entry room and the front of his
neck,
an entry wound looks entry for ruined entry wound looks so much different than
an exit wound and everybody knows that.
So you had to,
they had to come up with something by these fucking round hole in the middle of
this guy's neck.
So they decided to make it a trick scar,
which is just deception.
Yup.
Just that alone.
But you know we are led to believe that it's all official history.
It kind of like his rubber stamped and so much is it rubber stamp,
which is absolute bs on so many things.
And you know that is 50 years ago and when we're coming back to trying to find
out what really happened a thousand years ago,
you know when we got to do it,
the rubber stamp,
those motherfuckers,
it's those rubber stamp people man.
It really is that that really is what it is in the notion that certain things
make you a ridiculous person if you discuss them,
whether it's a Sasquatch or whether it's you,
fos,
or whether,
whether it's anything,
the idea that Schumann beings even exist and exist in this form with cell phones
and fucking space travel and airplanes.
And that is so crazy.
Just the reality of people is so crazy.
Um,
I don't know why anybody would argue any ridiculous proposition about aliens or
the possibility of,
of a life that we haven't discovered another planet.
It's like,
just think about how fucking weird we are.
You know,
we're co the fact that we even exist is so mind blowing and exist in this form
for sure.
It could be a,
there,
there could be Ufo is around us all the time that we can't see cause they know
how to hide.
They,
they,
there could be easily some way or are you just are just completely invisible.
It doesn't seem outside the realm of possibility that they could deceive us.
That they could figure out a way to be a tree.
You know,
you know why I mean,
and who knows if it be like the,
the idea of like cloaking devices,
like all the shit that we're coming up with.
Like where we project an image of who knows what the fuck is up there that we
can't see.
Maybe they're Asians.
Brian,
you need to just jump in front of a train today.
Well one of the questions I get asked Brian is where the cat style aliens in
this client's aliens?
Cats?
No.
What if up?
What if a Chinese people are
more aliens?
That human and when the Nibiru people came and the Annunaki came,
they just added a little more alien,
the little more chimp to like my people,
the Italians.
So like him a little more champ.
I believe that more than the tray.
You believe that more than them being a tree?
Well,
what about if they were the wind?
I mean there's a pull,
Davis is a guy who's a,
an astrobiologist from University of Phoenix and he's basically writing a paper
on non material technology,
which he basically kind of like goes like,
I'm going to talk about this,
but I have no idea what I'm talking about because it's so out there.
But he's basically saying that alien beings,
if they were to call me or if they came here,
that technology might actually not be physically real,
that it might be something kind of like,
you know,
some kind of energy cloud in front of them,
which they can direct with thought and can do stuff with that.
Um,
and you kind of think like,
well,
we're almost there because a few days ago there was some headline whereby I
think in Japan,
Asians again,
um,
where they somehow have been able to map.
If somebody is thinking about,
I think it was a tomato or something like that,
the computer could pick up the patent that this guy was thinking about tomatoes.
So we are rapidly moving in directions of really being able to pick up what
we're thinking and computer technology being able to identify what we're
thinking.
Yeah,
and who knows whether you're,
they're going to be able to enable consciousness to exist inside of computers or
consciousness to exist inside of a signal.
If you can get consciousness to exist inside of a computer.
Think about how much energy and how much information is distributed just through
wireless Internet.
Just flying around all around you constantly is fucking videos and ones and
Zeros.
And who knows if one day they'll be able to do that with consciousness.
Just broadcast consciousness like a wifi signal so that you,
you essentially are everywhere all the time if you choose to be so the aliens
are here without even physically being here.
Well,
you said that aliens were wind and the Wifi in the air,
so the Internet is aliens.
Dude.
What if the hurricanes in alien,
what?
I just smell than alien.
Did you do some?
No,
it's a child.
I apologize.
I missed coping.
She's fucking serious author here,
Dude.
You're just messing this whole thing up.
It when you,
uh,
you know,
when you tell people that you're on that show ancient aliens,
isn't that like automatically one of those things where they go,
oh,
okay,
you believe in aliens,
look,
oh,
you believe in Ufos?
No,
it's amazing in them an America that has been a complete change.
The answer is no longer no.
Really,
people kind of like go like,
wow,
interesting.
This is being explored as is being discussed.
Um,
you know,
it's got phenomenal ratings and it's got an attraction from five to 95 and all
of a sudden,
and I think this is largely due to the format of the show as well.
Um,
really people are into this.
People are beginning to question things.
I got feedback from university professors and specifically highs to high school
teachers and the high school teachers are saying,
you know,
we used to say something like very dogmatically something like,
let's say water is liquid.
Um,
they can still get away with that,
but some of the other claims they're making students are now challenging just
saying,
well,
where did he get that from?
And before there was this acceptance of,
Oh yeah,
the teacher says so.
So we have to accept whatever it is knowledgeable person says and we will just
write it down.
And all of a sudden high school teachers,
even university students are basically saying,
no,
we're not going to do that.
We're going to ask where this came from.
Why do you come to that stance?
And I think that's interesting and it's definitely something which is happening
in America.
Um,
because the series is also in different countries are kind of like going forward
in all countries.
Definitely in like Europe,
it's definitely still like,
oh you believe in aliens.
Well here's the thing that's happening in this country especially.
And it's a thing that you can call intellectual wealth and financial wealth
might still be locked down by the elite,
but intellectual wealth is no longer intellectual.
Wealth is,
look,
you don't really have to have any sort of formal education and you could educate
yourself just by reading the Internet.
You literally any subject,
any you,
you could find forums where virtually any topic that you wished to engage in and
what to figure things out about could be discussed.
You could go to,
you could download Birst,
virtually every book that's ever been written about it.
And it's,
it's not like it used to be.
So it's not like when they go into a college,
the professor is intellectually incredibly wealthy and the children are
intellectually poor.
No.
The children have fucking smart phones and they could Google anything.
Like,
no,
that's not why I was at 17,
26.
And they found it this way and that professor looks like an idiot now because
he's got some old outdated information.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
it's,
it's not easy to just run a bunch of kids.
Tell them lies.
Well,
you know,
what do you do with kids?
These fucking kids these days and they're aliens.
But the idea of aliens is always been sexy.
It's always been,
you know,
it's daunting.
Like the idea,
like,
wow,
what could you imagine?
If it is real,
what would it be like?
And that's why there's a thousand fucking movies.
I was going to say Hollywood down the street.
Yeah,
just look,
you know like it's,
it's one of those things where I don't know what would happen if it proved it
was proven to be real,
but I don't,
I don't think it would be good if they could prove that there are aliens and
aliens exist.
I think people are too stupid.
I think they're just start jumping off buildings.
I don't think they'd be able to handle it.
Yeah,
there's,
there's various scenarios there.
Definitely.
I mean,
you know,
the World War of the worlds thing from the 1930 Sweden,
Orson Welles.
Yeah.
It's kind of like the classic thing of,
of,
of the panicky situation.
Then there are those who say that was exaggerated,
that it was really isolated,
that it would the headlines of the newspapers who invented this kind of thing.
I don't know.
I mean I
depends how sexy the alien is.
I think it was an attractive alien.
We might not panic and jump off.
We might try to arrive and they're all hot as fuck.
Like Natasha Hendrickson species.
Remember that
maybe this is a conspiracy.
Maybe everything about the UFO cover up has happened because they were ugly and
they were not photogenic and to insect like,
and the government is just waiting for beautiful aliens to come and then that
will be this closure.
Meanwhile,
there's going to be a new movie about that very same subject.
Now that they've heard this,
someone will write a movie about it,
be awesome.
Hot Ac.
No,
dammit,
we forgot.
We forgot to copyright that.
Um,
yeah.
I think for,
for whatever reason,
I think people are barely able to handle this reality.
You know,
for whatever reason,
whether it's they're not living the life that they want to live there not around
too many people that think a lot.
They don't have much education,
they don't have a strong mind.
They have a lot of phobias.
They have addictions to substances,
whatever the fuck it is.
There's people that are a lot of people that are barely hanging on to this life
as is.
It's an awful lot of framework.
People love to have a framework and yeah,
going back to children,
children need a framework.
They need structure in their life and adults,
so many adults need to do that as well.
And once that framework is in place,
and I think this is tying it back to like the academic professors,
it's really hard to break out of that.
And it's,
it's like you know,
whether it is things like how cisgenic substances,
whether it is things like that.
That's experiences life after death,
all of these things,
aliens,
lost civilizations,
they all somehow are pushing this cardboard thing of the framework saying how we
need to get through because there's something outside of this framework and
basically people saying
keep it intact.
Yeah,
the ancient aliens one is one where I've had the conversation with people where
I sort of described the Zechariah Cichon thing,
situation scenario,
what could have happened?
And they look at you like they're trying to find a way to get away you like,
what the fuck?
Kind of stupid conversation.
Am I locked in with this idiot?
If you've never read any of Zacharias sitch and stuff,
I'll just summarize it very quickly and it's such and believes that we were
engineered by these alien beings and that it's all in the ancient Sumerian text,
his translations of it or all that.
These people came down and did genetic experiments on human beings and created
us to mine for gold,
which is really a trip.
It's really a mind fuck me.
Start thinking about how gold has always been valuable and you're like,
why you can't even make a sword out of it.
Like why did people back then,
why was anybody willing to take like a bag of gold for your donkey?
Like that doesn't make any sense.
Like why,
why,
why did it have so value?
The ZACHARIAE CICHON scenario is that they,
these aliens had ruined their environment and they needed gold dust suspend
their atmosphere to protect them from the radiation.
Well,
it's really fucked up is scientists didn't figure that like when they were
started to discuss possible climate change,
uh,
erosion,
the ozone layer,
what would they do to protect the United if we lost all of our,
uh,
our,
our ozone or atmosphere and the number one solution was to suspend reflective
particles in the atmosphere.
Like,
and so Cichon had actually translated this in the 70s.
This is like far before scientists had even proposed that.
So it's really kinda interesting,
like that's one little piece of that switch,
that thing that makes you go,
Whoa,
like who the f how did he figure that out?
It was that,
I don't know,
I'm not smart enough to know about the,
you know,
the environment and the climate change and how much they knew about the ozone
layer back in the 1970s.
But
when he was a very controversial man,
he,
uh,
he was very kind of like Edelman dead set in his ways and he wasn't the one
character,
but he definitely was an interesting character.
And,
um,
you know,
towards the end of his life to get to it in traditions,
his publisher,
he began to like push for the DNA analysis.
He wanted to,
to do some DNA testing.
And unfortunately he died before any of that could have happened.
But it would have been interesting to see where he was going to take it because
he really was pushing his,
his reputation and his legacy on the line there.
And again,
it didn't happen because he died.
But um,
it is the DNA evidence he was trying to find was that we were genetically
manipulated and created.
That's why we're so,
the idea is that's why we're so different from every other monkey that's here.
I mean,
we,
it's so clear that we're different.
We're so much different than all the rest of them.
And people are like,
well,
we are apes were just were from a different branch.
How the fuck did this one branch just take off?
This one branch has cars and this was one brand me.
Every,
everybody else is the same.
They're all just throwing their own shit.
Even the chimps that are the status,
they're in this,
the chimps have the baddest,
smartest motherfuckers the closest to us,
but look at him like,
oh,
they're using a tool,
they're sticking a stick to fucking get ants.
That's as close to a tools that get like,
whoa,
whoo.
You know,
call me when they figured out a bow and arrow.
Okay.
It's the difference between them and us is so gigantic and I've never heard that
adequately explained,
never,
never heard the fossil records baffling to a lot of biologists when it comes to
the doubling,
the human brain size are,
I've read all these different theories of why the human brain size doubled over
a period of 2 million years and they're all fucking north,
so it's all like,
Ooh,
knows man.
Who knows?
If we really found now conclusively that there was some sort of genetic
manipulation by some
genetic manipulation by some sort of an outside force that might be too much for
people to handle.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
it's,
again,
it's the framework.
It's like if we somehow were to be able to change time and I didn't interview
for a DVD,
which is going to come out of that thinking in a few months from now.
And it's about the Marcel family,
the ones who are involved with Roswell and two generations of them,
specifically the grants on Jesse Marcel.
The third grew up with the absolute conviction that Iti existed.
The family is absolutely convinced that what grandfather found was x address
jewel,
the dads at the age of 10.
So some of these artifacts and they raised his son and the grandchild I the
third.
Um,
in this absolute conviction that Iti existed and his mindset is completely
different from the rest of us.
It's like,
you know,
like at the age of five,
he's not questioning whether what he sees on television,
about Battlestar Galactica could be possibly real or anything of the science
fiction thing.
He just grew up with his complete acceptance that it is,
they're just like shamanic cultures believe absolutely.
That there are other entities out there that there is a larger framework out
there.
Uh,
you know,
so many people,
but the majority of us,
the majority of the normal people get raised in a religion.
They kind of,
you know,
grow up with that and then they continue to endorse it or they break away from
it and sometimes completely throw the baby out with the bath water.
Um,
and that is very interesting.
Kind of like,
you know how 2 billion people right now are,
are in this Catholic tradition all by themselves already of like having this
framework which has created for the last 2000 years and everything where you
look around you in this Western world is basically the cardboard box of the last
2000 years.
Yeah.
The Catholic one is wa.
That's where I started out when I was a little kid.
I was,
I was Catholic and the hair,
I can't believe there's so many people that are still on that.
That one's a tricky one.
That ones,
I mean like how much abuse do you have to take?
How many kids have to get molested by priests and how many times they have to
cover that up?
How many people have to live these horrible guilt laden lives because of that
wacky ass fucking religion.
But you see,
this is what the Catholic religion doesn't give any any shit about it because
this is what they're think about.
You are baptized.
That's all they care about for the rest of your life.
Where do you live?
Good.
Do you murder people?
They don't care because once you're baptized,
you god gonna die.
You do the rituals and all of that stuff and then they believe in a physical
resurrection of the dead at the time when Jesus comes back living right.
Or you know,
whether you are a pedophile or a mass murderer,
they don't care.
It's all about being baptized and that's all good and the rest is all pretty
much make belief and entertainment for the masters.
Well,
I don't think that's the case.
I think they care if you're a or a murderer.
I mean,
people don't want that in their community,
but I know what you're saying.
Then if you follow the dogma,
if you follow the actual word of the religion,
the most important part is that they're baptized so that they can possibly come
back.
It can go to heaven.
And that they,
you know,
that they,
what did they have to say?
They love Jesus right before they die.
They have to say that except Jesus into their heart.
Do they have to say it?
Nope.
Yeah,
you have to say it.
I have to say that.
That's the one to say it.
Do you always have that in the back of your head?
Like,
just in case,
like,
I'm like,
what is it again?
Okay.
I gotta do that.
No,
but this chick I used to date,
her roommate used to say shit like that.
It's just in case.
Just in case.
I except you to my heart,
just the case.
It's like,
it's always,
uh,
it's always good to better be safe than sorry.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Put on those purple Nike's.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's a,
it's,
it's just ridiculous how big it is and that those stories are far more
ridiculous than the Zechariah Cichon tale of humanity.
The Zechariah sitch until if you manage just like,
hmm.
That makes you,
I mean,
it's like,
we know what we can do.
We've got a rover on Mars right now.
We're collecting soil were taken for,
we know we can do that and we know that we did used to be able to do that a
hundred years ago.
So why wouldn't we think that someone could have been here a few thousand years
ago?
This is a young ass planet.
Planet's only been around like 4 billion years or something like that.
Right?
4.67 of them.
Creatine.
Yeah.
If you look at the earth,
the earth in comparison to the rest of the universe,
there's planets that are billions of years older than us out there somewhere.
Yeah.
And you know,
again,
as he was saying earlier,
it's like give a hundred years into the future and if they came here 8,002 years
ago,
how would you tell?
Yeah.
And statistically that they're all like,
you know,
people have been doing this statistical analyses and that would have been two or
three of these incidents happening.
Now,
first of all,
you know,
if his spaceship does crash in let's say 15,000 BC,
somewhere in America,
good luck finding evidence of that.
Um,
you know,
there's hardly anybody living here at that moment.
Wouldn't spaceships lasts longer though then?
Like I iPhones,
you know,
like your iPhone wouldn't be around for 10,000 years,
but a fucking spaceship,
that shit is pretty durable.
I bet it'd be around for awhile.
You would hope.
You would hope you're going to travel through,
uh,
you know,
galaxies with one of those fucking things are planets so young.
It hasn't even started it's period.
Right?
These are not good because you're not good lines.
You're interrupting the support and conversation with,
I apologize.
See the problem with those Brian is the dirt.
They're train wrecks and they ruined the flow of the conversation.
And now I don't even remember what we were saying.
The planet is just shut up.
Shut up.
Brian's,
it is a,
um,
an issue with people when they talk about the origins of humanity and they talk
about the origins of civilizations and how far we've come over the short period
of time and is an issue with people where there's no clear beginning.
It's like,
Ooh,
it gets foggy from Mesopotamia.
Something,
you know,
it gets real foggy.
It gets real foggy about five,
6,000 years ago.
And those guys were all talking about people that lived before that and they all
had stories of ancient civilizations that were more advanced and greater.
They all have these kind of catastrophe stories and they also all have like
these stories about being visited.
Yeah.
And I mean,
yeah,
the ancient Egyptians are probably the best example of this.
They have stories which basically say that they go back 25,002 years ago to a
time when the goats,
whatever they are,
um,
rules and we're present amongst the stand,
a disappeared.
Then there was some kind of debt.
My goals and then dynastic rule of Egypt can,
and that's kind of very much something that you find everywhere.
What do you go into Arizona?
And you hear the same story of the Hopis just period when the gods were amongst
the study,
still how it can be contacted.
And in the case of,
of the ancient Egyptians who have this disorder,
very interesting scenario that they speak about Atlantis.
And you know,
these wonderful Greek who have fought for so many generations dominated our
education as the cradle of civilization.
Well they themselves say they weren't the cradle of civilization to taggers says
he studied in ancient Egypt.
All of them went to ancient Egypt to study these things.
Yet we keep calling them Pataka,
Aristos and Euclid this and all of that stuff.
But they all say it came from Egypt.
So all of this knowledge came from Egypt.
And what happens is that in the fourth century when Plato starts writing about
Atlantis,
he says,
you know,
this is history.
He writes about it in a history book.
He has his critics because nobody in Greece's believing that somehow Athens is
thousands of years older than then.
They believe they are talking about a lost civilization somewhere in what seems
to be the Atlantic Ocean.
And that there's this continent behind it.
What kind of nonsense is this?
So as soon as he's written it,
basically a few guys jump on a boat,
go to Egypt,
hope that they can get confronted with evidence,
which shows that Sulan in plate or absolute morons who've invented this and they
arrive in the temple complex and the Egyptian priest kind of like points and
says,
Yup,
that's the column over there,
um,
which has this story.
And they jumped back in the boat,
arrive in Athens and basically say,
Oh yeah,
sorry.
Um,
you know,
yeah,
Plato was right.
The ancient Egyptians have this information about this lost civilization.
Now that doesn't mean necessarily that ancient Atlantis is real,
but definitely that the ancient Egyptians believed that it was real.
Um,
and all of that is,
is kind of like,
you know,
factual.
All of this is,
is identified as,
as being real.
We know that this guy jumped on a boat,
um,
and,
and that his colon was there up until the fourth century BC.
And what we have right now,
again,
this cardboard box,
which we were trying to maintain.
We had the likes of Ken Fedder who,
you know,
I'm all about the fact that there should be debate,
but it also has to be informed.
And this guy basically says,
well,
you know,
played to invent it as this is an idealized state and when you ask him,
but it's about history.
He says it history,
well that was a literary device.
He invented the literary device.
Uh,
he was very upset with the way Athens was being run and so he pretends that it
is history,
um,
and he really wants to expose that for and it's like,
oh,
shut up.
Um,
you know,
again,
right now there is no evidence that Atlantis was real,
but we should get to a point to say that there is some validity that it might be
real.
Um,
and guess what,
10,000 years ago,
we know that the water levels were lower.
We know that there was ice above things like Great Britain,
two miles of ice sitting there that begins to melt.
At the end of the last,
I'd sage to see levels begin to rise.
What's the story of Atlantis?
Have a low level playing somewhere near water,
which all of a sudden is,
you know,
submerged by water,
which comes out of nowhere apparently.
And submerge has this civilization.
It's what we have found.
Haven't they discovered the,
what they believe is the concentric circles that made up of Atlantis in Spain?
Well,
they have found so many things to the answer.
The answer is that our ancestors built in concentric circles everywhere.
Uh,
in the book gloss civilization.
In the,
there,
there is actually the work of a,
of a Belgian historian Marcel Mastec who finds that these circles also existed
around Stonehenge,
Avery,
but also in France.
Why did they do that?
Why did they build?
Um,
we don't necessarily know the,
the kind of like,
the indications are that our ancestors were very much aware of water technology.
They realize that they wanted to do certain things with water,
that they could purify it somehow,
that he could get more quality out of this.
That,
you know,
like it's,
it's somehow that they understood the qualities of,
of,
of water.
And we're only beginning to touch that there's some research,
concentric circles may have been filters
potentially.
I mean,
over the last 10 to 20 years,
people have beginning to look at this,
most of,
most of it in Russia.
Uh,
it is slowly coming back to us and kind of like the results of what you're
doing.
But yeah,
you know,
like a motto at his water and memory and all of that stuff.
That's also probably a good way to have building set up.
And if you had an these concentric circles and the water was inside of each
circle,
everyone would have access to water.
Yes.
And there's also something about,
you know,
like the proximity to water,
how this was somehow important and beneficial to health.
Um,
that water healed.
You know,
until a few years ago,
everybody went to these spots across the world to,
to partake in the waters,
which were meant to cure everything and indefinitely made our ancestors feel
better.
And that seems to be tradition,
which existed for thousands of years to take this past somehow that is water,
uh,
was important.
But also of course they had to make sure that what rewards pure,
that water was clean,
that it didn't contain,
you know,
things which would write a kill you rather than helium.
Well,
water is always been something that makes people feel good too,
right?
I mean,
it's gotta be helpful for you playing in the ocean and just,
Oh my wife,
my wife is a big supporter of,
of thing.
If you have a problem,
take a shower and there are people who actually say that the,
the physical fact of water getting on your head makes your brain think better.
Um,
and she's an absolute,
like she's an example of this.
She will sometimes go into the shower and come back and say,
this problem,
I'm kind of have the solution.
I think I found this.
She's not alone.
It definitely feels good.
That's one of the great pleasures of being a civilized person.
Take a hot shower,
man.
I went camping recently and I was camping for five days.
We're wore the same clothes,
no showers cold out,
so no showers,
no nothing.
And then finally we checked in in a hotel room on the fifth day and I took a
shower and I took a shot for like an hour.
It felt so good and it's,
I don't think we,
we have so many awesome things like that that we,
we don't even appreciate so much likely or it's very likely rather that these
people that even in Atlanta,
it's probably weren't as sophisticated as us and it comes to a lot of things.
But they did have different methods of,
of running in their society,
different methods of employing natural resources to,
to,
you know,
they didn't have a gas and oil based society.
So we have to look at that as well.
Like what when when you're dealing with people that didn't have machines and
combustion engines and a gas and oil based society,
you're,
you got wonder like how does this superintelligence of the human mind manifest
itself in a physical form?
Well it seemed like it did with stone.
It seems like that's,
that was where all the intelligence went.
All the thought.
And innovation went to structures and building these incredible geometrically
accurate structures.
Mm.
Well our ancestors I think had far more knowledge than we do.
And this is to some extent also visible,
I think in the work which Jeremy RBS trying to do with the pharmacology
industry.
Far More knowledge about what
knowledgeable about various things,
like whether it is plants,
plants,
how they can heal,
how we can use them.
You know,
today we kind of like say,
okay,
pill acts is made out of this and this molecule and it'll do this in your body.
Um,
and it this,
this pill which we can give you,
which we have created two lots of machinery.
And in the Amazon it's not,
it doesn't work like that.
They'll say what's wrong with you?
They will do the analysis and they'll say,
oh,
if we boil plant,
why four,
five hours?
And we mix it with plan Z,
uh,
the end result will be something which will help you with this.
It's knowledge base,
but the preparation is so easy.
You are the boil it or you take it in its native form or you mix them England's,
it's this very basic thing of,
of working.
But you need to have the knowledge.
You need to know that all of these plants work.
And today we have the big physical approach of like,
you know,
like we have machines and power plants which are able to produce this pill,
but the end result is the same.
You get better from taking this.
My take on it is that they knew a lot more back then.
Um,
then we think they did,
but they knew a lot about the natural world.
The knew a lot about healing.
But I don't think they had internet.
I don't think there have Google,
they didn't have cars.
We know way more now and we know about them.
They didn't know about us so they can go fuck themselves.
Anything even see us coming,
we're here.
Bitch,
you're not.
Um,
I think,
you know,
like computers and laptops,
what are the odds are they,
have they had all that shit?
Well,
you'd have to have oil to make all that stuff like that.
So the one component that people have to recognize in the construction of almost
every modern piece of technology is plastic and plastic is we can be made from
plants.
It could be made from hemp fiber,
but for the most part it's made from fucking oil.
And there's a lot of the shit that's in there,
it's made from oil and you've got a burn oil to fire up engines to fly over the
fucking sky to carry these things from China.
You know,
it's a,
it's a really,
uh,
being,
there's no way around it.
You need some,
you need,
you need to figure out a way to mass manufacture things in order to have a
society like this.
This is a completely different sort of society than they had back then.
Oh yeah.
I mean definitely,
but I,
I think that's this interesting thing.
Yeah.
The more academics denied the existence of Atlantis,
the more extreme.
Some people make the civilization as well.
Um,
and I think the truth is somewhere in the middle they were more advanced then.
You know,
like we have what you were talking about the four,
they were more advanced than the people who were running around doing nothing
whatsoever on the various other continents,
which is why the likes of the ancient Egyptian spoke about them of like,
Hey,
these guys did something.
these guys lived.
There just was,
you know,
like if you ever find something in your neighborhood of admins,
this might be related to these guys thousands of years ago,
but it's not going to be a spaceship.
It's not going to be something which is going to be so wow.
Wow,
wow.
But it is still wow in the sense that it was a large civilization.
If we take a Plato's word for it,
it was know pretty much Europe unified before Europe was ever unified and it was
also as a civilization which gave it's information to other civilizations there
it seems to be this,
this handover of information,
even though the civilization died,
not everything died.
Some of their knowledge seems to have gone over,
which is what the stories of the ancient Egyptians are about and how,
and you know,
there's somehow preserve this information from,
from their ancestors.
The most shocking thing to me about ancient man is the ability to move giant
stones.
That that one is the real mind.
Fuck well isn't the only thing to do back then.
So he probably got really good at it.
You know,
there's,
you got a lot of things to do,
dude.
You had a hunt and you had to gather and you had to make food,
you had to make shelter.
It's,
there's always shit to do.
Just being a human being.
And back then it was probably way more stressful to get your food than it is
today.
So I don't buy that or rocks just weighed the way less back then and your badge,
there was no way for us to judge that.
How much we know how much box way you silly fuck.
Maybe after years of rain it starts soaking it in and getting some kind of like
a wet towel,
wet towel effect for rocks.
Um,
some of the stones,
like those,
uh,
the,
the Lebanon stones and Bob back that just did just how old did they think those
are?
Nobody knows.
He can't date rocks,
but,
right.
I mean it's,
it's so many of these structures you can't date.
And I mean,
trying to answer the bell back thing via Stonehenge,
the traditional explanation of stone shares that it is 3000 BC,
but there's one guy,
Robert Langdon who is actually showing that these stones are probably 8,000 BC
and he's doing it by basically saying the holes which were found our 8,000 by
carbon dating results.
Some of the stones which are used elsewhere,
but specifically the blue sarsens are found in these holes 8,000 years ago,
sorry,
thousand BC.
Um,
so he's basically saying you are constantly putting Stone Henge and his 3000 BC
framework,
but actually the evidence suggests that it is 8,000 BC.
He's trying to push it out.
He's basically trying to,
to do the reinterpretations of this.
And in the case of Baalbek,
in the case of so many things,
it's always circumstantial dating.
Um,
you know,
this building has been repainted what year,
two years ago.
Um,
and imagine if somebody's,
you know,
five years ago says like,
Oh,
this building,
you know,
dates from seven years ago because the paint is,
is seven years ago.
Well that is circumstantial.
You know,
in the absence of you need to go further,
you need to be able to,
to find out more.
And in the case of this building,
you will probably find land registries.
You will find so much information which shows that it is probably 30,
40 years.
But in the case of things like bowel back,
you don't have anything.
You have a bit of plant life or some kind of discarded wood from an ancestors.
Um,
you know,
it's like trying to date Baalbek or Stonehenge or whatever monument by,
by a Twix wrapper,
which are tourist has left a 3002 years from now.
That's funny.
That's a funny way.
Or looking at it.
Um,
how big are those stones?
The Baalbek stones,
they're big.
They,
um,
some of the stones in the foundation of the platform are 800 tons.
There is one in situ which wasn't completely excavated,
which was 1200 tons is absolutely gigantic.
So how tall is that?
Is it like eight feet tall,
nine feet tall?
Uh,
I think to the 1,201 is,
um,
to
add,
those are about eight,
eight to 12 I think.
Yes,
it's Christ meters and feet.
And so what would be the theory?
Like what is the,
what is the standard theory
about how those people who were basically hunter and gatherers,
how they figured out how to do that?
They don't address it loud.
To me it's,
it's somehow like,
oh look,
they're there.
The Romans get this.
Um,
and,
and to large extent Baalbek is like that as a whole.
Um,
it is the second largest temple complex,
which to Romans built on top.
And parts of that haven't been explained by by traditional scientists either.
They kind of like,
we'll go like,
well,
you know,
some of these stones are 200 tons and we know that the ancient Romans were able
to work with cranes of,
of five turns.
And so they kind of go back.
So we need 40 of these cranes.
And you kind of got it.
Okay,
so why are you going to put them?
It's,
it's kind of like saying,
you know,
we need 40 people but your room can only hold five.
Where are you going to put the 35 extra?
You have to fit them somewhere.
These cranes around this piece of rock.
Um,
and so they do this all the time,
whether it's the Great Pyramid of Egypt and the pyramids theory about how they
are built as proposed by an archeologist is ridiculed by a project manager in
the building industry because they basically go like,
you can't do that.
You can't build anything like that.
Uh,
you know,
it's,
it's kind of like saying how many people do you need for the building of this?
And some archeologists will say,
oh,
10,000.
Okay,
fit them around this pyramid.
Put them all in line.
They play with some of these numbers.
And in the case of bowel back when it comes to the foundation stones,
like you know,
some will say,
well we know in the case of Jerusalem that the ancient Romans constructed this
and they were using things like 200 or 400 tons.
Great.
800 tons is pretty much double of that.
Um,
and we don't really know even how the ancient Romans did this.
They clearly did.
But how they did it in the case of,
of Baalbek is,
is a known,
we can speculate,
wooden rollers are,
are a great device leavers,
wooden rollers,
massive amounts of slaves pushing up.
But still,
but if you put a big stone on top of wooden roller,
the wooden rollers basically gets destroyed.
It gets incinerated through the weight.
So you ha if Bruton rollers were used,
somehow our ancestors were able to do something to that wood to make something
happened with that,
which would be able to sustain the weight on top.
You know,
it doesn't seem right.
Fell.
No,
I mean,
and here's the thing.
This is what bugs me so much.
It is the fact that so much of what our ancestors did remains unexplained on a
very mundane level.
You know,
the most basic things as to how Stonehenge was built,
how Avery was built,
why it was built,
how this mode was Doug Baalbek,
Jerusalem.
So many things,
it doesn't get explained by scientists.
And the reason why is that archeologists dig these things up and then somehow
treated as if it's their bailiwick and they're going to come up with the
explanations.
Now,
an archeologist is good with a shovel,
but he has no idea about the building industry.
He has no idea about project management.
And as soon as some of these people from the outside basically say,
em,
we know some of these things.
Would you like us to help the ocular just say basically fuck off.
This is our garden.
This is our playground.
We don't want you.
Wow.
Okay.
What have you,
and now have you seen a,
you,
I'm sure you've seen that video,
ancient aliens debunked.
I did.
And you wrote a piece about it.
Have you seen his theory about the interior ramp?
How they're constructed it?
I saw that.
I thought it was fascinating,
but it's still,
the,
the Great Pyramid is still so bananas.
It doesn't,
it doesn't help.
Just knowing that they made a ramp doesn't help for folks who don't know the
numbers.
This is a root cause.
I used to do a bit about the pyramids.
The Great Pyramid of Giza has,
what is it?
2 million,
600,000 stones.
And if you cut in place 10 a day,
it would take you 664 years to build.
I read that somewhere.
Just 10 of those monster fucking stones a day.
It would take you 664 years to make the pyramid like that.
Is that,
is that,
that's such a crazy accomplishment that building?
Well,
I mean,
a great friend of mine,
um,
he's unfortunately having to take care off off his dying wife.
It's Josie to Vidovich and Joseph to Vidovich is a French professor.
He's called the father of his own signs,
Chia polars.
And basically in the 1970s what he was looking at was he looked at rocks and he
said like,
okay,
I know how rocks are created,
geological process,
volcanic activity,
but is that a way I can recreate rocks in my laboratory?
And the answer was yes,
he was able to accomplish it as any called DC geopolymer.
And basically geopolymer is a natural rock,
sorry,
isn't,
is a manmade rock,
which looks almost identical to a natural rock.
Now there are certain differences in limestone for example,
you know,
you see these little mollusks and all of these other things which are in there
and there will need the aligned because the,
the,
the water came in and the wave came out and they are all perfectly aligned in a
geopolymer.
That's not the case because basically somebody has tested in,
in some structure and has basically over a period of 24 hours to 48 hours,
create a distinct,
so he went to Egypt on a holiday in the 19,
late 1970s where his wife,
family,
um,
look that degrades pyramid and said,
shit,
this isn't geopolymer.
All of these blocks are made.
In what I have just discovered.
And he began to point out on the Giza plateau,
40 easily identifiable features in about these drugs,
which anybody who goes there with his book and see for themselves that this
isn't natural stone.
Um,
in the end,
don't even disputed though Ryan hasn't that,
that mean that that is a,
the geologists are not agreeing with him.
Well,
certain ones that have actually put up a stink about that.
The grade.
Do you think about that?
It's the great first one.
Uh,
doctor [inaudible] who was,
who,
who has an,
he basically said he,
he is an idiot.
This is not cement.
Um,
and it isn't cement,
you know,
a horse has no idea what he's talking about.
Since then,
the likes of Michael Barr,
assume who is a professor,
I think in a Detroit University or somewhere in America University,
he has taken pretty much the,
the,
the roll up there from,
from the Vidovich.
Um,
they have submitted samples off of Geo polymers to some of the ancient Egypt,
sorry,
to,
to Gypsy in departments,
uh,
Libre laboratories.
And they basically said,
oh,
this is natural limestone.
To which,
you know,
bar Suman and the village said,
no,
it's not to be created at a few weeks ago.
But the basic problem is this.
We have a professor had father of a science,
a guy who has metals left,
right and center.
And the archeologists basically say,
go away.
This is our playground.
We're not even going to listen to what you're going to say.
Instead.
We're going to pretend that what you were saying is that the great pyramid was
made of cement and we know it wasn't made of cement.
And that is kind of like the sad thing.
And you know,
when it comes to project management,
when it comes to all of these,
this disciplines,
they basically say f off,
we don't want you here.
It's our playground.
It's our Sanford.
It was,
so there are,
uh,
actually,
I'm looking at this there,
there are many people,
very,
very intelligent people that believe that this is made out of concrete.
So the,
the propaganda may actually be the people that are disputing it because,
uh,
some scientists from MIT,
um,
they,
uh,
it seems like they,
believe I'm trying to read this as I'm doing it.
Um,
yeah,
they,
they believe that this,
uh,
it's very possible this was a,
what they're calling a limestone concrete and that they just made powder and mix
it there.
And that's why they're all perfect because they were caught,
they were poured into a mold,
which is far easier to do because then you're just carrying bags of shit up
there instead of actual pyramids.
Pyramid stones rather.
I mean there's one stone which he points out again,
like,
you know,
his books are mostly in French,
but he has self published one in English.
Um,
and basically he points at one stone where there is wedding in the middle.
Now,
wedding of a stone in the middle of a stone doesn't make any sense whatsoever.
How is this,
this,
this Po,
this possible.
And the only reason why it's possible is because at one point in time,
probably at night,
they mixed on the port one stone to a certain level and the following day they
completed it to the next level as a result of which to weathering could both at
the top and in the middle of this stone.
But again,
you know,
throughout the pyramid complex,
he's able to,
to show you and guide you around potential evidence because again,
there needs to be more research done.
But 40 points is,
you know,
more than one.
Um,
to Kinda like do an indication that this might be the case.
And the sad fact to me,
the thing which,
uh,
me is that the scientific establishment just basically says,
fuck off.
This is his actual position.
This makes it actually even more interesting.
His position is that only 10% or 20% were cast and that most of the blocks were
cut.
This is the w w what he believes that said,
most of the blocks were carved as suggested by archeologists,
but 10 to 20%.
We're probably cast in areas where it could have been highly difficult to
position the blocks.
So that's,
that's why they can show you blocks that haven't been cast and say,
see,
see these,
these the unquestionably were cut,
this guy's a fool.
But actually it makes a lot more sense.
Like they figured out both.
They figured out how to cast blocks and move them into positions where it'd be
much more difficult to cut them.
And they also caught them as well.
Yeah,
they're fucking really a mind blowing civilization.
He really try to wrap your head around where did they get all that information
from?
And then you look at their own history and it says they were,
they were hanging out with God's fuck man,
it sounds so stupid.
If you buy into it and believe it and bring it up at a,
at a,
um,
you know,
a dinner party.
But if it was real,
what a mind fuck that must event.
If human beings really did coexist in the same place as aliens and they were
really were teaching us and their big giant dudes like the guy in promethium
[inaudible]
is that possible man?
Do you think that's possible?
I think that that definitely is something to be said that our ancestors were
absolutely in communication with nonhuman intelligences.
I don't think that in a number of cases it was physical presence,
but definitely that they were in communication with something and that they
could establish this bank.
It's like,
you know,
like it's not like some contact,
which I should put this and intimate and phone signal.
It's a constant line.
They can kind of like go to whatever,
a statue or something in a temple.
And this uplink downlink thing works greatly.
Um,
and there's also something to be said.
All of these cultures across the world,
they always say that,
you know,
the,
the offspring of,
of the gods somehow became the rulers.
Um,
and that is definitely something which is another universal constant.
And you know that again,
genetic memory is,
is,
is one of these things,
it's been poo hard in,
in the the 19th century,
the ideas of Collagen and all of these things have been pushed aside,
but we have a hundred thousandths of,
of primitive cultures elsewhere who basically say they can access this pool of
information on a regulated basis.
And you know,
I am a firm believer that certain hallucinogenics substances really take you
outside of this cardboard box outside of this framework and that they take you
into a world of,
of intelligences and that our ancestors were given the tools and the techniques
to basically establish this link.
And once this link was established,
he could pretty much just these intelligences whatever they wanted.
Um,
and then it was up to the intelligence as I guess,
what did he say?
Yeah,
we'll tell you this or no,
we won't tell you that.
Um,
and I think that is too large extent what our ancestors were saying about this
link of the gods being present amongst them,
that somehow they were able to sustain a presence.
Um,
you know,
in a number of occasions.
It seems to be specifically in,
in kind of like the what I would say the non traditional societies,
some of them which have escaped most attention,
uh,
remote tribes in,
in China,
uh,
and,
and things like that.
There might have been a physical alien creature running around there for a
while.
Um,
but in most societies,
specifically the famous ones,
it somehow seems that these gods were non human intelligence is not necessarily
physical but definitely present.
Then somehow in communication with our ancestors and how that went.
Very few people knew back then.
And
do you think that's from psychedelics and that was the communication method for
the non nonphysical entities?
I think it's definitely one possibility.
I think it's,
it's something which we can go and say this is how it could have happened.
That sounds so stupid to anybody who's never done mushrooms.
But if you have,
or if you've done judge doesn't mean about mushrooms and they're saying that
it's what they thought happens when you do mushrooms is totally wrong that your
machine that shuts off your brain like your,
your whatever the mushrooms doing to you.
It's almost like it like flips your switch
and it runs a show with mushroom.
Well,
you know what,
what?
Yeah,
well mushrooms are,
is very closely related to human neuro chemistry.
When you take a mushroom mushroom is like,
I forget that the chemical way to describe it,
but it's for Fox,
for old oxy and,
and dimethyltryptamine.
I'm not saying it right,
but it's an [inaudible] trip to me as a part of human neural chemistry.
So this stuff,
this silicide is like,
it's like human neuro chemistry with a little added something to it.
And when,
when it hits you,
it basically takes over the show.
Crazy.
Fucking really crazy scarier.
Well,
it is scary.
The idea that Mckenna always had was that it was a,
an artificial intelligence and that,
that we were eating it and that's how it was communicating with us.
And then he came here from other planets.
Yeah.
That's why it's so different.
Apparently there's the,
there's no other organism on this planet with the phosphorous and the four
position according to Mckenna.
I don't even know what that means,
but,
uh,
like,
like psilocybin and he believed that it probably came here as spores and an
asteroid.
And that's,
uh,
that's,
that's why it has such an unbelievable impact.
It's like when you,
when you,
when you have a mushroom experience,
if you haven't had one before,
it doesn't seem like it could ever be possible.
You're like,
this is no way.
How does,
how,
how did I not know that this was a possibility to folks who haven't had
psychedelic experiences?
The idea that a psychedelic experience could somehow be otherworldly
intelligence.
Like I hear,
um,
Richard Dawson,
who I'm a huge fan of,
uh,
I think he's a brilliant guy and,
he,
Richard Dawkins rather,
and,
uh,
his,
all his breaking down a fundamentalist religions is,
I think it's a fantastic stuff.
But then when I've heard that the guy had never had a psychedelic experience,
I'm like,
my God,
you have to know that there's so many books and so much work written on the
connection,
which a w the,
the connection between what they call entheogens or psychedelic substances and
higher states of consciousness,
revelations,
religious experiences.
Like why would you as an intellectual not want to experience that?
It's not like you'd never come back or it's not like it fucking,
you know,
red lines.
Your brain sends you into a,
uh,
a mental tree.
But I think it's because the,
the,
the definition of a psychedelic is that it puts you somewhere which isn't real.
So it's of no interest to explore that.
Why would you want to create,
why would you,
why do you want to explore?
I think that is a very silly way of looking at reality.
I think that the idea that we even understand what that's doing to you,
it all that means to me is you haven't done it.
That's all it means to me.
If you really feel like you have some concrete definition as to what's going on
in that state,
and I most likely say you probably haven't done it before because if you have
done it,
he'd come back very humble about your,
your opinions on what's going on there.
It's too weird
and that's when you know what our ancestors are saying.
They had this entire system of initiations and what we're discovering is that
through a series of fasting,
sleep deprivation,
psychedelic drugs,
whatever it is,
and all of it together combined,
they basically pushed you out of your comfort zone and it was the high level.
You know you were going to experience your ancestors,
you are going to experience to gods.
You were going to really find out that you will not learn in the universe.
And this is pretty much the everything which are our ancestors are saying.
And like in the book I say,
you know at some point,
relatively early on,
thirty thousand twenty five thousand years ago,
we figured it out.
We figured out that this cardboard box,
the things which we see with our senses is not everything there was to reality.
We figured out that there was something larger there.
And we began to speculate and think about as to why we were here.
What was this,
you know,
why,
why did we run around here,
what is this thing in the mind?
And then,
um,
you know,
they didn't have computers.
They didn't have all of that stuff,
but they were thinking about it and they were experiment based.
And to large extent we are back to where we are because right now you have,
you know,
surgeons in hospital environments who are pushing little axes or little weird
things on top of machinery where the patient will never see it.
But when the patient says like,
hey doctor is the little thing on top of this thing there,
um,
doctor,
we'll kind of go like,
how did he know you had a near death experience?
He went to,
he had an out of body experience.
You,
you somehow were able to pick this up through nonsense,
nonsense,
the remains.
Um,
and you know,
we're back there,
but as a whole,
again,
jumping on my high horse here,
um,
science isn't interested.
Science basically says like,
it's nothing to do with this.
It's religious.
You were never going to look into these things and,
and what you have is this,
this standoff for this stalemate or whatever situation we're in,
whereby people hunger for information,
um,
nobody who has the tools and,
and to some extent of schooling to give us the answers is interested.
And so at the other end of the,
the prospective,
you have wild theories.
You know,
you have the fact that the ancient Atlantan must have had helicopters and
machinery and all of these things.
And guess what,
you know,
I actually don't care too much.
I don't believe it,
but I don't care too much that it's out there because it seems somehow,
you know,
Eric [inaudible] had to say that the Nazca lines were a spaceport before the few
scientists went to Peru and studied them and try to preserve them before 0.001
was interested and it was a lone woman.
Um,
you know,
basically trying to convince the locals not to drive over in that trucks over
and over the Nazca lines.
She was the only one interested,
nobody else was,
it took a guy to say,
hey,
maybe the gods have landed here.
Maybe this is a space board before they were pushed into action.
And so,
you know,
the fact that people are making sometimes extremely wild claims might hopefully
push these people,
these scientists off their butt into the field and do actually some of kind of
research to disprove things just to,
to,
to just to just do some yeah.
Something on it.
Do something.
And you know,
in the case of the Nazca lines,
what they have been discovering since it's so great to have this corporate
pyramids,
they have discovered that these people had a high civilization.
Um,
there are even potentially,
um,
there are even people out there who,
who really began to realize that what was happening there had to be seen from
the sky or understand what the Nazca lines or I just felt filled them in because
some,
some people might be ignorant to it.
Well then as clients are basically gigantic geoglyphs,
some in the shape of monkeys and other animals that are quite often and mostly
famous art alliance which just criss cross,
they have basically been made by sweeping off the top,
so top layer of surface off of sand and below it there's quite often a,
a wider surface.
So they stay visible for hundreds of years because it's a desert condition.
It hardly rains at all.
Uh,
on that plateau.
And you know,
it's come to a point where,
why people have said,
okay,
they have to be seen from the sky.
And there are a few scientists out there who've actually seen that some of the
rocks near the,
some of the,
some of the lines were exposed to extreme height.
Uh,
they also began to see that some people were actually varied with extreme
heighth.
Is He,
sorry.
Sorry.
Eat.
Um,
there were also people who were buried with um,
basically what we would describe as hang glider material.
Um,
and so they are beginning to find out that these people took to disguise and one
of them has actually proposed that they had balloons,
that this is why the hot air basically was encapsulated and they went to the
sky.
Other people you know,
are pursuing things like kites.
All of these things,
um,
all of a sudden are becoming,
within the bailiwick of,
of the potential.
People are looking at this and see whether this is possible,
whether they can find evidence around Nascar.
And so,
you know,
this,
it took somebody to say,
hey,
this thing needs to be seen from the sky.
Um,
before w people are really beginning to say,
oh yeah,
there is something to this Nicka civilization.
There were pyramids there.
You know,
this is a,
this isn't not an important civilization.
Which ones there,
well,
that is a crazy concept that they might have had some sort of air travel,
some of whatever.
They figured out some sort of plain or or something.
Now if it was just hand gliding,
would that be enough?
There's definitely evidence that there was some kind of hang gliding.
Obviously the environment was allowing for that as well.
I think people would try that shit.
If you get to the top of a a big cliff and the wind is blowing like crazy and
you see a bird doing it,
you know that some crazy motherfuckers going to try and make a wing.
I mean that's probably always been people.
People will probably always try to figure,
put some animal skins and strap it down.
I mean it's,
it's like you're just mimicking what you see right in front of you that already
works,
you know?
Wow,
that's crazy.
If they figured out some sort of rudimentary air flight,
I mean actually the kind of,
I believe the latest Boeing's to the seven three,
seven and an old 800 series of that.
They have like these little things at the end till the winds,
which stickup now and it's the Boeing engineers looked at at some of the birds,
specifically the birds of prey and they realize that these birds had little
feather at the end as well.
And so he began to test in the wind tunnels,
whether putting this thing at the end of the wings of planes would help.
And it kind of improved stability and all of that stuff.
Like,
like,
you know,
like percentages,
which really were kind of like out of the,
out of the norm.
Like nature birds are super fliers and we just mimicked them when we are
designing aircraft.
One of the most fucked up things about that area around the Nazca lines is those
skeletons they find with the long dated heads where these people,
they,
they took their heads of the babies and they select smushed them to form.
Like they tried to get them to look like,
like aliens.
Like,
like you would think of if you think of an alien,
you think of someone with a really big long head,
you know,
and they did that on purpose to their head.
I mean,
again,
these are the same like you and I,
your child would you subject your child to wooden planks and years of basically,
you know,
probably not,
like abuse into school,
um,
by,
by having these elongated skulls.
And they say,
did it because they,
somehow these children were special are going to be special in a sense that they
were going to resemble the gods.
Brian,
have you seen that shit before?
Pull it up.
Google.
Elongated skulls.
Just,
just Google that and you'll,
you'll see a,
I bet Peru is even more specific.
It's a,
it's a very,
very strange practice and yeah,
and it was really common.
They fee,
it's not like they felt like one or two of these they've found like fucking
burial grounds filled with these fucking things where they stretched out
people's heads.
I don't know how the,
no.
Do you know the number of how many of these different skulls they found?
Uh,
it depends.
I mean we're talking about hundreds when,
when it comes across to worlds and it is a worldwide phenomenon.
Like you know,
one of the images there I had to do with,
with one from Egypt,
they are found in North America.
They are found across the world
and didn't toot common,
have a very long Gaten had himself but seemed natural.
But what an oddly shaped head himself.
Well in the depictions,
him and his dad were depicted as such.
Yeah.
Um,
he had a normal skull as,
as a,
as a human being,
but he wasn't picked it as this weird wait
creature.
Now,
of course his dad,
which we all see him miss his economic,
uh,
he's really depicted weirdly apart from a weird hat.
All of his joints are,
are weird as well.
And again,
they're trying to explain it the way of his,
he had more felons or something like that,
some kind of disease.
Um,
which basically means that you have deformities of your fingers,
your bones,
but they haven't found his body.
Akhenaten's body is missing.
And I find it interesting then one of the potentially more interesting bodies,
Oz is missing in action.
Um,
if anybody knows the whereabouts of economic,
there's body,
please help.
Um,
because he was an interesting guy.
He absolutely took over a,
a system of,
of ancient Egypt and basically set to it all mistaken.
Um,
you can experience the gods in certain other ways and I'm going to push forward
with my religion and basically tell you how it is.
And I think what happened was that in his case,
again,
district trepanation of with Alan gating skulls,
um,
it has to happen from birth.
And I think his revelation happens.
Um,
obviously he was a teenager or an adult when he had it.
He couldn't travel back in time and do it to his own skull and tooth and common
I think was already too old as well.
This is speculation,
um,
to,
to have it done to,
to him.
So it would have been the next generation basically to 10 comments children
where they could have performed it on FDA.
So wanted to,
but an art Davey are depicted as such if they could,
well,
it,
it seems like a in art in might have been exaggerated,
but it does seem like there's people that are saying that the skull itself of a
to 10 common was elongated and is the skull of a,
his family,
apparently other members of his family who else was of his family was alive.
Right,
right.
I was his wife.
I think he had a sister.
Um,
I think he had some deceased people who were,
um,
dying before him.
Again,
the great controversy as you know,
did he die naturally?
Have was he murdered Robert and um,
[inaudible] have written about it in,
in their reason Duke and then it's a great controversy which doesn't want to go
away.
Yeah.
That's the,
the most recent one.
This is a,
the,
the National Geographic saying that,
uh,
he was not murdered violently that CT scans show.
Huh?
What a fucking nutty find that must have been.
They found that in 1926,
Huh?
How margin just dig in and you hit that thing in the middle of that sandy asked
desert where there's nothing going on and you all of a sudden hit this
incredible treasure trove of artwork and just this insight into what it was like
back then,
how many of those tombs were there that just got found and rated and just
stripped of all their wealth.
So many of them,
the majority to what a,
what a huge,
huge,
like a loss for history because just what we found makes you just go,
what the fuck was going on back then?
When you look at the sarcophagus and the golden that guild work and you're like,
what?
This,
these people were living in so much differently than anybody in Europe.
Yep.
Yeah.
And I mean,
just,
you know,
like in the new world in Corey Conklin Cusco,
you had an entire temple made out of gold.
You had Colton animals.
The entire core chart was made out of gold and a Spanish came,
they melted it all down,
put it on ships to sail back to Spain.
And English pirates basically sang to ships and all of that gold sitting at the
bottom of the sea.
And so,
you know,
it's kind of like double sad because it was first melted.
Uh,
there are stories that,
some of it has been secreted away,
uh,
people in,
about one in every 50 years.
There's,
there's a guy who comes forward and says,
like,
I was led into certain aspects of,
of,
of basically subterranean parts of this original structure.
And there is still something there.
Um,
people like Javier Sierra have,
have written a fiction books about them and that one hasn't been translated from
Spanish into English yet.
But,
um,
there's,
you know,
there was so much gold,
there was so much treasure and so has disappeared and it is so sad to see that.
So little remains.
And it was just one guy,
he was a minor ago.
He wasn't minder of Pharaoh.
Nobody cared about him.
Ramps is,
was so much more important.
Just imagine what he would have had.
It's crazy.
It's really crazy when you think about what they could have discovered and we
know so much just because the two tongue comments discovery,
um,
it's saying that the,
uh,
examinations of a scroll though that he did have an elongated hell,
head probably wasn't as exaggerated as the,
the images.
Um,
but he had a impacted wisdom teeth as well,
and he had a cleft palate.
So they know that the,
the,
the medicine was not up to par,
you know,
so that's at least good evidence that if this guy was a pharaoh because they
didn't understand basic dentistry,
they didn't know how to fix cleft palates.
So they,
they weren't ahead of us with everything.
You know,
they,
again,
they were very good at certain things,
but they were crap that others like,
I mean the ancient Egyptians for example,
as much as they build things,
they never built things like arches.
They were able to build bridges,
but they never built artists.
Now it's possible that they could build arches,
but they basically didn't think they were aesthetically pleasing.
Um,
but certain things like,
you know,
what we would think they would have been able to do,
they might not have been able to do.
And,
but at the same time,
you know,
building structures with hundreds of tons of stone in there,
whether it's the valley pyramid complex,
um,
or,
or the great pyramid they were able to do.
And people often say when it comes to the Great Pyramids,
Oh,
like,
you know,
okay.
It was only the,
it was the Eiffel Tower last century or two centuries ago now,
uh,
which,
which rivaled it.
But actual score that is indeed somewhat along in it.
Yeah,
that's his actual skull.
That's the actual cat scan of his skull.
If you could pull that up,
Brian,
we'll get took a look at that.
But it's,
but that's nothing compared to the images.
He's got a fucked up head for sure.
He'd make get made fun of in high school,
but he didn't look like an alien.
It's probably why they put him in private education major.
What if he did have a fucking giant brain?
What is the,
the pharaohs were like more that would,
if they originally had some alien and them eventually got bred out.
Is that possible?
Well,
I mean,
again,
it's possible if somebody were to do research into it,
to explore it.
What we know is that our ancestors set that all of these kinks were partly
human,
partly divine,
and that they were here to make a bridge between our world and the world of the
gods.
That was their job.
And if they were unable to do that,
they were quite often kicked out and basically told,
okay,
we'll find another one or substitute for you.
The ancient Egyptian Pharaohs,
uh,
if specifically when they became older,
um,
we're quite often told to to perform a hab sad festival,
which was basically a fitness test whereby they physically and mentally had to
prove that it could somehow communicate the world of the gods.
Um,
you know,
that is clearly as a job specification day.
They were told to do this and clearly it means that this communication with the
gods for dumb somehow involved a physical aptitude thing.
It wasn't that they were simply inventing certain things,
uh,
you know,
they were basically told you need to be physically fit to do these things.
Whether it is true having synergenic substances,
some kind of,
you know,
other means,
which we haven't been able to identify.
But across the world,
the job of a king was to be an enabler or a bridge between us and the world of
the ancestors,
the gods,
whatever you want to call them.
I think it's very difficult for people in this day and age to wrap their heads
around the idea that at one point in time the whole reality of human beings was
very,
very different than it is now.
But if you stopped and thought about it and if there was some introduction or
some uh,
um,
intervention rather have some sort of alien consciousness.
If physical alien forms and then they weren't there anymore and they weren't
there for thousands and thousands of years,
how much would we know how much evidence will be left?
What,
what would be around that?
We could point fingers at,
well there'd be like stolen crowd carvings that show giants holding small
people.
They have those,
they really do have those.
I mean there,
there is some,
a lot of ancient art that the,
the,
the ancient Sumerian stuff is the weirdest stuff where it actually has double
helix DNA that we,
the ancient Sumerian,
like I've had a conversations with people that try to deny that they had some
knowledge of the workings of the solar system.
Like it's really,
you have to be crazy.
You look at their,
their what they've,
what they left in stone tablets.
Like they knew where the stars were,
they knew where the planets,
they knew the constellations.
They knew for sure they knew what was going on in our solar system.
They knew where the planets were.
They had them in the right order.
They had like little grant and people would try to say no,
that's not the planet.
So those are just some stars.
Like what are you talking?
Why is there the right amount?
Why they're the same size.
Why is it in proportion?
The big ones here in the smaller ones,
they're like,
that looks like the sun and the solar system.
It looks like our planets.
Right.
And you know,
family,
basic things like nab guidance seems to be this metal plate which has a moon and
a settling it.
And then some kind of like bars and you kind of think about,
oh how sweet our ancestors were trying to depict the sun and the moon.
Elanco clever of them are little ancestors.
And then some people start to analyze this for real and they realize that if you
hold it in front of you,
you and you directed to the horizon,
these little bars,
which you might think are of no significance whatsoever,
mark on the place where these were found in Germany,
the position of the rising of the sun and the setting of the sun on things like
the solstices and equinoxes and all of a sudden you kind of go,
Oh shit,
it looks stupid.
But actually,
you know,
it's a very clever device.
What's the name of this device?
It's the neighbor disks.
[inaudible] Sky Neb Ra.
There's a one thing that you talked about in your book that we've talked about
on this podcast before because it's uh,
it's always fascinated me that device.
How do you say it again?
What's the antica terra device?
Explain that thing cause that's a mind fuck and a half.
Well,
the antica terra device is basically a piece of metal,
which was heavily corroded,
found in the ship wreck off the coast of Greece in 1901 or 1902.
It was put in a museum where it's sat for several decades.
And in 1950s and sixties,
a guy called Derek the price solo,
sorry,
Derek desoto price and became interested in this.
And he began to look at it.
He began to study this and he felt that is somehow was a scale model of our
solar system thrown in some kind of uh,
constellations,
throw in obviously the moon,
throw in some zodiacal signs.
And he began to experiment with this.
Uh,
he pushed it theory forward,
which was attacked because we all know that the Greeks are stupid and we're not
able to do this because,
you know,
the earth was flat,
wasn't it until somebody in the 16th century,
um,
proved otherwise.
So he was attacked.
But in the last 10,
15 years,
and specifically with computer modeling techniques,
what they have found is,
is basically that the direct price wasn't 100% right,
but that he definitely had the right frame of mind that this was basically a
scale model of our,
of our solar system.
Now,
what they've been able to show is that the Greeks were using Babylonian things
like metronic cycles about the moon.
Um,
that basically this device was taking in [inaudible] information from ancient
Babylonia,
Greek,
uh,
native to Greek things,
general information about,
uh,
you know,
how the earth has 365 days to go around the sun and all of that stuff that they
made this device,
um,
which basically,
you know,
would have had the sun at its middle and then all the plants going around it
that this device actually worked.
That is kind of like what's put in motion and then continued watch for the
universe.
Yeah.
And or those sorts of sort of sources.
And um,
they think because they don't know,
you know,
this device was fan.
So they go into ancient accounts and ancient Greek accounts and trying to find
out whether anybody is talking about the 10.
They have found sporadic references to people basically saying this would sit in
the temple.
So somehow our ancient Greek ancestors were creating these devices.
We're putting them into temples to basically show how the universe work.
Imagine that,
you know,
imagine going into a Christian Church right now and finding a scale of the solar
system in there,
but for the Greeks,
that was apparently what they wanted.
And we have,
what does the idea of how old this thing is?
Um,
the device is probably second century or first century BC and that is what
remains of it.
So it's at 2000 years old.
Yes.
Fucking Christ.
What is the,
what's the academic response to like what do they believe it is?
Um,
they are silently accepting really they are,
um,
they basically,
you know,
they realize they can't contest its origins.
It's found in the shipwreck.
They can't contest that.
It's 2002 years old.
Um,
so they have to accept for what it is.
They have to accept that there are gears,
um,
where day rebel at is if somebody would push the boat out too much.
So right now they connect say,
well,
you know,
it's an,
it's a representation of the solar system but it has some errors in there.
Um,
and to some extent they can get away with that because basically what we have is
a piece of material which wasn't seawater for 2000 years and it is painstakingly
being kind of like,
you know,
how many wheels is it?
Does it have here?
How wide is this?
All of this is reconstruction,
which is going to take decades more before we have a completely accurate
representation of what is device was sort of corroded and mushed together.
Completely corroded.
Obviously you'd sits when a museum,
which basically means that they are very reluctant to do destructive testing or
anything of taking apart.
So it relies on technology to go through this piece of corroded material and
come up with better images,
better imaging software and all of that stuff too,
to identify what do wheels precisely where.
Um,
but basically the overall picture is this,
that the ancient Greeks were able to do certain things,
which we didn't give them credit for.
Um,
and very slowly,
um,
you know,
the academics are kind of going,
yeah,
okay,
that's fine because it's safe.
It's ancient Greece.
We've credited the ancient Greeks with an awful lot of these things and even
though it sits somewhat outside of the bailiwick,
but like you know,
we don't really want to credit them with a machine.
I mean people actually refer to it as the first computer.
Yeah.
Spelling.
So folks,
cause I know people are scrambling right now to figure out how do you,
how do you spell it?
Antica terra anti as in we don't care about them and Katerra.
K Y t h e r a.
So go check out that if you really want to get high in the middle,
almost like a third.
I think that's just a screw or a bolt or something like that.
The whole thing is fascinating.
Oh look at that.
That's 2000 years old that they were making something so complicated.
I think a steering wheel.
It does.
It will look,
it looks like.
Yeah,
it could be.
You look like it could be like a really ancient clock,
which is 2000 years ago and that obviously was from some technology that we
don't understand.
We don't know where they got the information from.
We don't know anything about it.
Nope.
But what we do know about it is that,
you know,
again,
our ancestors were more intelligent.
We're more clever than we standard,
give them credit for,
and it's also a good representation of what happens to something just 2000
years now.
If you think about what 2000 years is to human history and then go back and say,
well,
this guy,
the Egyptologists was like,
where's the evidence of this 10,000 year old culture?
Where would that stuff be?
10th at eight more thousand plus years.
That's not gonna exist anymore.
It's obviously corroding away after 2000
and if you come to the last Ice Age,
10 12,000 years ago,
pots of Britain,
we're under an ice sheet,
two miles thick.
It washed away everything.
It changed to out of health.
Any hut which we would have had there any piece would have just been completely
obliterated by the power of the ice.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's another thing that people have to take.
Any consideration when you think about how long people had been around,
like we had to move around a lot.
Like there's there spots where people were around that were all raised by miles
of ice,
slowly crushing everything in its path.
Literally like a giant eraser.
You know,
I a lot of people on Twitter,
like we're freaking out about the two,
two common thing showing me all these images of how they get babies,
his stretch their heads out.
It doesn't mean that he's an alien.
I'm not saying to Don Coleman was an alien.
What I am saying is,
and I think it's fascinating and I don't think,
I don't see how it could be disputed that all of these people who are stretching
their baby's heads out are trying to get their babies' heads to look like what
we consider the classic image of aliens.
That that's,
to me,
it's very weird.
It's very weird that you would want to do that.
Like I don't understand.
I know that there's weird things that people do culture a little,
like they stretched their necks out,
they put plates in their lips.
There's a lot of wacky shit that people do,
but that one to me is really interesting when you consider the fact that you're,
you're dealing with some culture that may or may not have had something to do
with space flight or you know,
or,
uh,
air flight and,
and they did it because they say to resemble the goats,
to assemble the ancestors.
That's why we do it like in a nipple piercings and all of that stuff,
which might be considered weird in some cultures.
We know why they do it.
We know why we do it.
There's always a reason which we can identify.
And in this case,
the reason is because they want it to resemble the gods.
Then there's another thing that I saw you touched on in this book is how many
different pyramids and structures they're finding in South America.
Yes.
It's really bananas,
isn't it?
Well,
I mean,
you know,
I wrote a previous book called a new pyramid h five years ago.
And that book is actually completely out of date because,
um,
and up until 1994 when Robert both,
I'll Roti Orion mystery.
We had this idea,
there are pyramids in Egypt and their pyramids in the Mayan culture and that's
pretty much it.
But now,
um,
and specifically around 2006 and seven,
every single week,
some pyramid was found somewhere.
Um,
and we are in a situation right now whereby the academics agree that the oldest
pyramids in the world are in Peru Chorale 2,800.
Now the Egyptians could be older.
We have carbon dating results as we were saying,
but they refuse to publish them.
But you know,
officially to corral tournaments are older,
the largest one volume wise,
our latch DiLulla in Mexico as well.
And then,
um,
height wise there is a new contender in the Bosnian pyramids which might
actually be 220 meters I 660 yards high,
um,
which is pretty much quite a bit higher than,
than the Great Pyramid.
All of these things is,
is really changing the pyramid landscape.
And also what is happening is that we're beginning to understand why the
pyramids were built,
why,
um,
these structures were,
were there and there is this kind of like uniform template which basically says
that our ancestors somehow build pyramids because they were linked with kingship
and somehow enabled our ancestors and specifically the king to once again be
this bridge from one world to the other.
What is the controversy about the Bosnian pyramids?
Cause I know even Robert Schoch from Boston versus who doesn't believe that it's
a,
it's a manmade structure.
Then the controversy is that there is very much divided between western science
and former East Bloc signs on this.
Um,
it is very much maintained,
um,
you know,
by a small group of people.
But in the archeological establishment,
Antony Harding is one of them.
He was the former president of the West and,
uh,
sort of European archeological society.
And he basically said that if he found any archeologist digging on the Bosnian
term side,
he would forever make sure that this guy or woman never had any other job.
Um,
the reason I think why it is so controversial is because they are not in
control.
The license went to San Jose [inaudible] who has three PhDs,
one in history,
mine studies one,
um,
in,
in business.
Um,
and another one who's I've forgotten,
I think it's in,
so in anthropology,
um,
actually no something in economics.
Um,
and they realize that they were too late to realize that,
you know,
this was going to be run differently than traditional archeological digs.
And they made up some incredible,
you know,
bs about it.
Like what happened early on was that,
uh,
San Jose [inaudible] road to Zahi Hawass,
um,
and wanted to need,
uh,
basically wanted the geologists who come and study these pyramids.
He sent Doctor Rati Barakat Barakat stayed there for roughly two months.
He did the analysis and he said that these pyramids were manmade.
Um,
he,
um,
was then attacked by her,
was basically saying,
I never,
I never sent,
Barack got there too,
which was [inaudible] basically.
So the letter signed by Havas saying like,
you know,
what is this?
I was there in 2008.
I've been there a number of occasions,
but I was there in 2008 when the first international conference on the Bosnian
pyramids was being held.
You had the people who were in charge of the Chinese pyramids,
um,
who basically doing the excavations cm,
uh,
involving such things,
you know,
as,
as the emperor who,
who unified China that with 30 of the leading Egyptologists Stair,
the current minister of antiquities,
Mohammed Ibrahim Ali was one of the,
the,
the people present there.
Uh,
his,
he was at that moment in time to deal with volcanology of ain't chains.
Um,
another dean of archaeology of Cairo University was there in short term,
you know,
30 off deleting Egyptologists and geologists from,
from,
from Egypt who were there.
When you go onto things like Wikipedia.
However,
the opening sentence will be that the pyramids are natural phenomenon,
but I would invite anybody to click on the talk page of Freaky pedia when it
comes to the Bosnian pyramids.
And you will see a guy called dog dweller who's constantly over there and he
gets asked the question.
Um,
somewhere on the talk page,
basically saying,
well,
in 2008,
this committee of,
you know,
remember they were discovered in 2005 first excavations happened in 2006,
2008 was the first time,
uh,
when all of these scientists get,
or they have since scattered in 2011 and 2012 as well.
Um,
but in 2008 to recommendation of all of these scientists was that they should
continue digging and that there was evidence to point out and to suspect that
these were more than likely man made.
Since then,
there has been more evidenced there when the quellar is asked,
why can the conclusions of the international conference on the Bosnian pyramids
in 2008 not be mentioned on the front page of the entrance of the Bosnian
pyramids?
He says,
well,
people who believe in creation have these semis pseudo archeological conferences
as well.
Um,
and Wikipedia should not adhere to these things.
Sure.
But in this case,
when it comes to the Bosnian pyramids,
the leading lights of archeology signed off,
physically signed off with their signature on these conclusions from 2008,
but there is this idea,
you know,
that we should not look at it.
And again it has to do with why.
What about Robert Schoch though?
Cause he's not,
Robert Schoch went there in 2007 when when very little was,
wasn't covered.
So much more has happened since.
Um,
and I would actually invite him to,
to go back.
I would invite everybody to go back.
Um,
so convincing they have done pretty much more excavations.
They have found,
um,
you know,
at that moment in time of the tunnel complex,
pretty much what you had in 2007 was roughly 75 yards of have tunnel complex.
It looked like going in one direction for 40,
50 yards and 25 yards in another direction.
Since then,
they have found a thousand yards of this.
They have found that it loops back.
They have found exposed areas where they didn't have to even scrape anything out
where it just is.
They have found underground rivers,
they have found gigantic stone bulgur swing eight tons lying in the middle of of
these things of these tunnel complex as they have,
you know,
dug up elsewhere.
They have found how,
for example,
treat pyramids saw perfectly.
The tops of them are perfectly equidistant.
They have found how on certain dates of the year,
the pyramid of the sun costs the shadow precisely on the top of the Pyramid of
the moon.
All of these things are,
you know,
things which have been discovered since 2007 and what shock was looking at in
2007 was very little.
They kind of like,
you know it,
it's almost kind of like going into your garden and saying,
Hey,
I've,
I've hit this patch.
It's,
it's 10 inches wide and it's a stone and it might be something completely else.
And you ask a guy about the 10 inches.
It seems to me that a go Beckley tabby was the first real significant monkey
ranch that they had to discover.
You know that they had to,
they had to admit that this fucking thing was 14,000 plus years old.
There's no getting around it.
And it is a [inaudible] this point,
I believe it's a 5% has been Escovedo.
Is that what it is at now?
Yes.
I mean,
did they keep going say the percentages go up?
Yes.
And it's so it's a slow process.
The s excavation,
so five,
5% of it has been uncovered and it was purposely covered up 14,000
yes.
So it's so incredible.
I mean like,
you know,
they'll kind collect,
tell you,
oh and you know,
t shaped columns,
blah blah,
blah this,
but look at the images.
This is treat,
I mentioned carving of,
of animals and kind of,
yeah,
that's the two folks who understand the,
you know,
like when you like say if you had a flat wall and you wanted a car of a monkey
into it,
like you would just draw the monkey like you would on a two dimensional piece of
paper.
That's not what they did.
They actually made it larger and then cut the monkey.
Or it wasn't a monkey,
but they cut like the lizard.
They cut different animals out of it so that they stuck out and then the rest of
it was flat and smooth.
So it all came from one giant piece of stone and they had the technology to trim
everything else straight around it,
get to that one spot and then construct this little relief animal.
It's really weird.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And you know,
I think it's,
it's on something on power,
which we again don't see for thousands of years.
Ancient Egyptians did it somewhat,
but I think really it takes us to gothic times.
Then Cathedral building,
when you see some of these intricacies once again on this plane
and it's all built at a time where they believe people were just a 100% hunter
gatherers.
When you go back to 14,000 years standard,
the standard academic model is that people were like really unsophisticated back
then sitting on the boat.
Yeah.
Just chasing animals and throwing sticks at him and shit.
Meanwhile these people,
and they found this,
cause the dude was just like sheep herding and he found a rock.
Yeah.
He like kicked this rock was moving around with the fuck is this.
So he starts digging around it then realizes what was it,
nine feet 19 feet tall.
How many feet was the column?
Yeah,
I,
I've I've done who the exact dimensions that they normally like somebody in the
1960s you know,
had had to look at it and I'm the,
the thing was like,
oh this is a medieval Byzantine Sam cemetery of no interest whatsoever.
And then everything happened in the early 1990s there now people who are
actually beginning to do investigations into it and are coming up with stellar
alignments and the fact that these ancestors who built go back to the tab,
he had knowledge of the stars.
And what is interesting is not simply that they had knowledge of the stars and
the constellations,
but that the kind of stars and constellations they were interested in happens to
be the kind of constellations which other cultures like ancient Egypt and the
mines were interested in the work as well.
So you have this continuum of,
of,
of knowledge and you know,
the more research is going to happen there and go back to the happy,
the more is going to be exposed.
And there are actually pockets of,
uh,
of other structures in the yoga back,
the tappy,
which are actually slightly older,
but again,
it's going to be piecemeal given to us,
um,
as to how we are older and more interesting than we really think we are.
The whole thing is crazy.
They're 10 feet high.
Those,
uh,
these giant t shaped monolith pill monolithic pillars there,
limestone and uh,
there's a,
another bigger pair of pillars is placed in the center of the structures.
It's craziness.
And again,
it's an enormous site.
Like they're just slowly starting to piece it together.
What do they use?
Do they they x ray the ground or something?
How they find out how big it is?
Yeah.
Doing covered it,
yeah.
To doing basically GFS.
And this is just one of them is just one of them that might exist and we can
easily stumble upon one and a year.
That's 10,000 years older than that.
Yeah.
Oh,
I mean,
you know,
corral the pyramids,
which we were talking about just now in,
through,
um,
40 years ago,
people looked at them and said like,
they look like shit.
They like,
they don't even look like anything man made.
And guess what,
you know,
erosion destroyed these things.
It's like picking at the end to Katerra device and thinking this is just a piece
of,
of crap.
Um,
that's 2000 years old.
Things change,
you know,
put,
put a a long play record in the sunshine and we know what happens to it as well.
Um,
but we need to recognize that sometimes we miss identify it and then we go back
and we say,
Oh shit,
this is so much more interesting than,
than we originally thought it was.
And that is happening relatively a lot.
To go back to the Tapi is an example of that corral pyramid says and those are
one of them.
It's fascinating that the more a culture advances the more easily it's records
are destroyed because in the beginning you just carve and shit on rocks.
And then when it gets to us,
we got,
you know,
micro USB cards in your fucking cell phone and you know,
you lose that little fucker,
you know,
it's gone or you know,
late leave it around,
it gets stepped on a couple of times.
It's done,
you know,
leave it in the ground,
the ground will eat it and absorb it in a few years,
it'll be gone.
It's a,
it's fascinating to think that if we had some sort of a reset button,
like you look at this hurricane that just hit New York and New Jersey and the
massive amount of devastation that it did.
And just on a purely practical,
I've like how all of a sudden these people are unable to survive.
We really need to send very basic things like clothing and food out to them.
Um,
you know,
it,
it just shows you how reliant we are on technology to keep our food fresh,
uh,
to keep our food frozen,
to keep us warm.
And when that isn't there anymore,
we are unable to cope.
We do.
These people really need help from the rest of us because we have become so
overly sophisticated that be can no longer survive in said,
and we are here in southern California until we get an earthquake.
We don't even know what the fuck whether is,
we are completely detached.
That's why some of the most clueless people live here.
The the,
there was some of the people that are the most detached from nature and from the
concept of the fact that we are a part of an ecosystem and we are in fact on a
planet.
Because when you live in Florida and one of those motherfuckers come through and
you realize that this is possible,
that the earth can possibly have this sort of a crazy violent,
powerful reaction is very humbling.
It's very humbling and it's and it,
and it makes you like,
oh,
we've got to plan for this.
Okay,
we,
we've met,
we might have to dig holes like deep in the ground and cement the men and,
and build some kind of a shelter that you could survive through this because
being on the surface is not an option.
Here in California.
We don't have that every now and then the ground moves,
but we forget about it.
It only moves like every couple of decades.
Everybody freaks out,
moves to Colorado and they slowly creep back in and everybody pretends it never
happens.
It just keeps on going on building houses on the side of hills with stilts.
Have you seen those fucking things?
How hilarious are those coming from what you know about a ancient history?
Like what are you doing with this temporary house?
You have you silly bitch.
Yeah.
And you know,
but here's the difference.
I think,
you know,
our ancestors would just like us.
They wanted to build that beautiful house.
They wanted to have that beautiful view,
but they made sure it wasn't built on Boyden sticks.
They made gigantic foundations in stone.
This is the reason that I can like ball back is,
is uh,
you know,
say seismically active,
but definitely not as much as things like Cusco shakes every five seconds.
And the Inca civilization built for this.
They built gigantically weird shaped stones,
um,
in,
in all shapes whereby we know day withstand earthquakes.
Um,
you know,
is that why they have things that,
what curvy fit in like jigsaw puzzles.
Lovely.
Because you know,
what happens to Sherman oaks was an epicenter and I think the 94 earthquake and
basically two plates kind of like made houses jump up.
And then from the other side they basically gave them a different sellers so to
speak.
Um,
and so because we build so linearly,
um,
you know,
houses,
I mean I'm slightly exaggerating here,
jumped up and Jim,
Jim,
Jim down again.
Um,
but because all of these stones can kind of go,
okay,
we can't jump,
but we can't show that.
We kind of like,
we're stuck because we are so wedged with these other stones.
They earthquake resistant and our ancestors understood this.
They employ this.
But somehow,
you know,
despite some of these billion dollar 12,
okay,
slight exaggeration,
million dollar houses in Los Angeles,
the architects don't seem too willing to borrow from our Inca ancestors when it
comes to two designs.
Planned obsolescence,
that sort of,
as no one's making a house,
it's going to live for 10,000 years.
They just want a house as good for like a cop.
100,
insulate it,
make it eco.
How long have your solar panels good for the solar panel?
Even good for a hundred years
I think.
I think it,
I think they mostly outdated by the,
by the ability to get like near,
they want to be replaced because they constantly keep doing better ones,
which get more power out of them.
Now you wrote a rebuttal to the,
it's a dude who made that video,
which was the,
yeah,
Chris White who made,
uh,
the,
um,
it was ancient aliens debunked and essentially he pointed out errors that
existed on the television show.
And then you made a,
you,
you rebutted his,
his video.
What did you feel like it was wrong about his video?
Well,
there's,
there's several things wrong.
And you know,
one of the things is that he,
even though he's not your traditional skeptic,
he does betray some of those things.
Um,
he will go and read something on the Internet and we'll say,
well,
on the Internet I found something else.
Um,
and some of the science,
he references like rational Wiki,
which is basically a skeptic Wikipedia.
Um,
and he'll kind of like say,
look,
this guy shows you how,
um,
when it comes to the people in my hand,
your Daro,
um,
how they were,
you know,
like on ancient aliens,
it is said that these people are lying hand in hand in the middle of,
um,
of the street.
And this guy says that they were buried.
Well,
this guy's article is actually online and this guy actually says,
when they were doing initial excavations in my hand,
your Daro,
they were done.
So crappily that it's,
uh,
you don't know it is open for speculation.
They might have died in the street,
they might have been buried.
Nobody knows.
And this guy says that himself.
Uh,
he then goes on to to basically say,
but in my opinion,
they were buried.
So he's basically siding purposefully towards the skeptical thing when it's
still an open point of,
yeah,
I mean,
on a number of occasions,
I agree with him.
Like,
you know,
there are certain things which people hold the allee and we'll say on camera,
uh,
which I don't agree with him.
You're fucked whenever Giorgio goes with Georgiou sucralose goals.
Is it possible?
Oh your mother fucker.
You got man,
cause as soon as he does that,
dude,
it's fucking,
everything's aliens is possible.
But I mean that,
that's like,
you know,
I mean my biggest beef with,
with him is,
is to do with crystal skulls.
Like he makes it appear as if he cannot,
he comes up with this new media and says like Anna Mitchell hedges never,
she always tried to sell the crystal skull and she never allowed for scientific
dating.
And I said like,
well she did,
she gave it to you.
Look Packard.
Um,
and she gave it to the British Museum and he then comes back and says like,
what I know about the British Museum,
uh,
analysis in 1936 I even mang mentioned it in the documentary and you kind of go,
no,
you're actually referring to you yourself claim to have read this article.
In this article,
there is a photograph of animal [inaudible] hedges in the British Museum when
she was doing the dating.
By the way,
there's an entire video of it,
which the BBC mate,
uh,
in 1980 or 81,
and you can see Mitchell hedges in the British Museum with the British Museum
school and her school there.
I'm talking about the 1980 stating,
but that is,
you know,
that is,
Chris is,
again,
he's not your typical skeptic,
but he does this thing of like,
I have found something on the internet which says something differently,
therefore you have to be wrong.
And there was definitely a lot of shit that he was right about.
Right.
There was a lot of errors that you pointed out.
He,
he make some clever miss directions though with some of it as well.
Kind of like,
you know,
like,
yes,
Georgiou is wrong when he says diorite or whatever the other one is.
Um,
but it doesn't change anything to do with the density or the hardness of,
of that material.
He also comes up with kind of like what I think is sometimes the mids direction
of like he's,
he'll kind of say like,
why is David Hatchery Children's talking about levitation?
Um,
when it comes to the Easter island statues,
one,
they could have been put on wooden rollers.
Well,
the reason why David had her children's is talking about it is because the local
say that they walked,
that they were floated in to space.
So ancient aliens is discussing the possibility whether it is possible that
there was such a thing as levitation.
It's a question mark.
You know,
we are exploring the possibility that our ancestors might be wrong.
Our ancestors actually don't say that they were put on wooden rollers.
They might have been put on wooden rollers.
Um,
you know,
that might've happened.
Our ancestors might have complained and speculated and said like,
oh,
well,
wouldn't roller sounds so boring,
let's say the levitated.
Um,
but it is about the exploration of the possibility and this is what ancient
aliens does.
It's saying,
should we take our ancestors word for it?
Is this possible?
And then,
you know,
it's up to the viewer to,
to decide whether or not it's the case.
But the biggest beef I have with Chris White is the following.
Um,
and it is very clever what he does.
He says,
no matter how many mistakes I have found by the fault,
I know that the ancient alien theory is wrong.
So even if he finds nothing wrong with the ancient deal in a series,
he basically says in his opening and his closing,
I know that this is impossible.
Um,
and he does a very clever trick as well,
which is,
um,
basically he says,
you know,
okay,
I found one evidence here,
I have found.
So one area here,
I had found another railroad there.
The third one,
they're great.
That's 50 hours of television.
You know,
if,
if you find 50 errors in there,
uh,
it's quite good.
Um,
but he sees every evidence as evidence of somehow there's a vast conspiracy by
us to,
to Ms Director.
Well,
there's certainly,
let's be honest,
there's certainly a confirmation bias that's involved with almost every fringe
subject,
whether it's goats or big foot or aliens.
There is a,
an unquestionable confirmation bias where people who really want to believe in
it find ways to believe in it.
But it's the same.
A traditional archeologist is up to xy.
He has loss.
We'll find clues in there to kind of like explain certain things away as well.
It works on both sides.
Yes,
totally.
Right.
I absolutely agree.
Especially when Mr Huw os he's famous for,
he's funny,
isn't he in trouble,
wasn't even going to go to jail.
He,
he cannot leave the country.
What happened?
What'd you do wrong?
Some fashion shit.
Yes.
Basically sit and money disappeared in the ses.
Who would've thought that guy was crooked?
Most people are like,
what?
God,
what Dorks or these guys,
they're do there.
They're doing it.
They're gasbag about Egyptologists certain guys,
bitchy Egyptologists.
Um,
I thought that what he did was a very brilliant,
uh,
take on mistakes and he was very time consuming and tedious.
And I,
I thought it was very well done and I can't wait to talk to him about it,
but my problem is that there's still a lot of courageousness to that stuff
saying that,
you know,
they had done and moved larger stones before and that somehow or another,
because of it was a,
a part of a foundation wall wasn't that one.
It was that it wasn't so impressive.
Like look,
the Baalbek like that,
that's kind of crazy.
Like there was a lot of where you're trying to find some reason why it's not
fantastic and it's obviously fantastic.
Yeah.
And I mean,
you know what I,
and this is probably a sign of our times,
but ancient aliens is a TV show.
It tries to put forward into the public mind.
Is this possible?
Here's a bit of traffic intonation for you.
Um,
and by default,
the ancient aliens,
the series is not identified with whether or not we have been visited by the P
in the past.
I mean,
the best evidence was put forward by the likes of Carl Sagan and shows Ostrowski
in the,
in 19,
late 1970s,
Carl Sagan,
who was very much a skeptic,
he didn't believe in anything like crop circles and all that stuff.
Um,
and he basically said,
you know,
of Paleo contact,
where do we have been visited in the past or not,
or not.
The best example is the one,
it's this creature which comes out of the sea and teachers,
man,
the arts of civilization,
various other things.
Uh,
one is disappeared and other creature came up,
uh,
basically to cuff where you began to instruct people.
What does this from,
this is from Babylonia.
It is actually,
it's,
it's a Babylonian rendering of a,
of a Sumerian mythology as well.
So basically the Babylonians were repeating what they got from,
from the Samaritans.
And basically they were saying that from the Persian Gulf thousands of years
ago.
It's not too clear when precisely this creature came.
Um,
he came out of the sea,
he took off his kind of like fishy outside and underneath was a human hat and he
began to instruct our ancestors on the arts of architecture,
um,
mathematics and art and all of all of these sciences.
Man,
that's a good way for aliens to go in the water first and then pop out.
Hey,
we were here all along.
Yeah,
that's better than coming from the sky.
You know,
you're like,
I was right behind us.
True sort of.
I came here from another fucking galaxy.
Um,
I mean,
you know,
in the eyes of Carl Sagan and many,
uh,
people who are looking into this from it,
from a scientific point of view,
this is kind of like amongst the best evidence that we might have potentially
been visited by,
by,
by ancient aliens.
Chris White doesn't even mention it.
And it's kind of like,
okay,
you should really try to negate this.
If you want to pretend that you have completely destroyed the ancient alien
theory,
you know,
you can try and attack the ancient alien,
ancient aliens to series.
Um,
but if as long as you don't go for the best evidence,
like through on a story and you do it on a scientific level,
you kind of like,
you know,
you,
you argue why Carl Sagan thought this was interesting.
Wireless scientists thought this was interesting.
Then really you,
you can make a documentary and pretend that you have completely destroyed the
possibility that we were ever visited in the past by,
by ancient aliens.
But you haven't,
you can just do that at the end of your documentary and you're no better or
worse than the narrator on ancient alien series who says,
you know,
could have,
we could,
we have been visited by aliens and the pants on the same level.
I see what you're saying.
You,
he's not considering all the evidence.
He's trying to prove a point and it's,
there is a possibility,
no matter how many mistakes you guys make,
there are still a possibility that the human race has been visited.
And in fact,
maybe even engineered by advanced lifeforms.
It's,
it's absolutely a possibility.
Well,
you know,
when it comes to such things as,
as,
as astrobiology,
it's,
it's one of my great passions in the ancient alien question.
I write about it and I thought when I was going to write that chapter,
it was going to be boring.
It was going to be at some point in the past,
there were some scientists who thought that life came from elsewhere in the
universe riding on a comment or a meet to ride and then it crashed here.
And then all of a sudden we had life on planet us.
Um,
and it's so different.
What we have right now are astrobiologist who are working for NASA who are
saying that the building blocks of life are spontaneously in interstellar space.
That as a result lifelike us is potentially everywhere in the universe.
Um,
you know,
they have been saying that fire buses,
um,
are more than likely some of them more than likely are coming from,
from outer space as well.
Um,
did you see that one?
I think it was from Harvard,
uh,
the astronomer that's a,
that it's very unlikely that we'll ever find life and there is probably no life
anywhere but earth because we've looked at 500 planets and we have found no
life.
And I looked at that and I said,
no,
no.
You've looked at 501 planets and one out of 500 has life.
What did Edison say?
I have found 202 ways of not making light.
I mean,
I just find that fascinating.
It's so,
it would be so arrogant when life does exist on this one.
That's so dumb.
Just because you looked at 500 other planets,
if it's one out of a thousand,
that's pretty amazing.
When you consider the hundreds of billions of stars just in this galaxy alone,
I,
I don't know who you're referring to,
but like,
you know,
if,
if he was the traditional sets,
I guy who looks a bit radio astronomy kind of stuff,
NASA is a banding that they realize you're looking for a needle in a haystack.
It's built on so many assumptions.
Um,
no,
the bandwidth where they would be able to broadcast this NASA has basically
abandoned is they're looking at us through biology and they're basically saying
that,
you know,
there is now more than substantial evidence that indeed life,
um,
didn't originate on on this planet,
but that had a somewhere else in the universe and that it came here,
this theory of Panspermia,
which Francis Crick,
who was the guy who identified a structure to do the double helix of DNA.
He always said it didn't originate here,
that it came from somewhere else and NASA gas,
what the greatest astrobiologists in the world can't get published in peer
review journals because the peer review journals are still so adamant that life
originated on planet earth.
So NASA is doing science by press release day.
They do the findings,
they get them peer reviews amongst their,
their,
their peers.
They know they can't get published.
So they published them on the Internet and everybody can consult them on the
Internet.
And the guys who do the peer review journals,
they're now saying that NASA is involved in a conspiracy to convince the world
that life exists elsewhere in the universe as well.
It's kind of like,
okay,
it seems like shades of what Galileo had to go through.
Just a more advanced form of arrogance because we have more information now to
back up our claims and we can make these big grandiose statements like,
well we've examined 500 planets.
We're pretty sure we're alone.
Like that is so silly.
If you think of how many fucking plan it's the right there is.
This guy's examined 500 of them.
They think they got it fixed.
You better get back to work,
bitch.
You better go do your homework cause that's,
that's bananas.
So silly that you can even say that.
Like the numbers again,
it's like
we talked about how 7,000 years is impossible for people to think about.
Well that ain't shit compared to the number of stars just in this galaxy.
When you start getting into the,
the,
just the phrase hundreds of billions and then think about each one may have,
who knows how many goddamn planets.
It's not,
you can't do it.
It's too crazy.
It's,
it's,
it's too hard for people to,
so when a guy comes out and says something like that,
I'm like,
are you just trying to get attention?
Like what do,
what do you think of when you see a press release?
Um,
yeah,
I do see an awful lot of,
of kind of like headline grabbing tripe type of people who try to,
and specifically,
you know,
scientists has become about this scramble for money.
Um,
we need to be in on it and on a completely different level.
Like,
you know,
this was very much in evidence,
but Jesus wife controversy,
which hit like,
you know,
like somebody found this scrap of material,
which basically only could ever prove that in the third century.
And there were people who believed that Jesus was married to Mary Magdalen and
all of a sudden you have this enormous stampede of scientists saying,
no,
this can't be true.
This is,
I have found this,
that let me do research.
Um,
and they're basically kind of saying,
give me money and for the rest of you know,
five years,
I will debate endlessly about this and I will create this controversy about
that.
And it just escalates like,
you know,
because it's Jesus and we know Jesus has more than controversial.
The likes of National Geographic actually pulled the initial documentary,
which wasn't done by some kind of,
you know,
crazy person.
It was a Harvard professor who,
who basically came up with this.
Um,
but it is like,
you know,
like she basically,
it's in private possession.
Uh,
she had made this deal with the guy that she would take all the slack.
She would if she had done the analysis,
this was old.
Um,
but she wasn't going to reveal who the owner was.
Fine.
Is that so controversial?
But then all of a sudden you have scientists saying,
no,
we need to know who the owner is.
Because if we don't know who the owner is,
we're going to completely,
you know,
not believe anything you're saying.
And it's like,
oh,
come on.
Is this,
you know,
kindergarten or as this academics,
and unfortunately it's kindergarten.
It's a,
it's really fascinating that at the highest levels of intelligence,
the highest levels of knowledge,
the,
the place where you're actually supposed to go to,
to get that stuff,
that things are withheld bait just on the basis of ego,
just completely on the basis.
There's things that are not considered because people don't want to look
ridiculous,
and there's certain subjects that you're not even allowed to study or consider
because they can be bad for your career.
They can ruin your career.
Just even study them like it must be very,
you have to be a very brave person to admit to having a fascination with
psychedelic drugs.
If you're a scientist,
if you're an archeologist and you suggest the possibility,
just the possibility that there may very well have been ancient civilizations
that were unaware of,
we have an on that
immediately throws you into a certain fringe category.
Right?
Oh,
I mean,
I was around John Mack Havac,
professor of psychiatry.
He created the Psychiatry Department at Harvard University.
And in 1995,
he became involved with the entire Ufo abduction thing.
And what he was saying was he had looked at these people and these people were
reporting something which in his opinion,
which coincided with what other people were describing as when they saw,
uh,
you know,
a car driving through a red light and they were describing it.
He said,
these people are not making this up.
These people are describing it as if this has reality to them.
This is something which they relate as relevant to me.
That soul.
He wasn't saying it was real.
He was basically saying,
everybody who I've interviewed,
um,
is relating it to me in wording.
Um,
which suggests to me that it is something which has happened to them.
He went a little further than that and his second book,
the second book,
I read both of his books and the second book,
uh,
he was basically relaying the message that these aliens had told these people
about what we know,
what the consequences of human destruction and what we're doing to the planet.
It's,
it's all pretty fascinating stuff.
But what always killed me about the John Mack stuff is that everything happens
at night.
All these people were abducted at night.
We know during the nighttime the brain releases and dodginess bursts of dimethyl
trip to me,
which is an incredibly powerful hallucinogenic drug.
Like why don't we get these people who have had these alien abduction
experiences and introduce them to intervene is dimethyltryptamine and see if it
recreates the same thing.
Cause if it does,
then you know what you got going on,
you know that you have doesn't mean it's not a real event.
And exactly that's the point he was making.
Well we have this idea that something is only real.
If you could pick it up in a way at,
yeah.
You know,
if you have this and you can,
you can saw it and half,
well then it's real.
But there's,
it's very possible that there's chemical doorways that exist and there something
goes through them,
something returns or the resonance in which you interface with the universe
changes because of the introduction to the of these alkaloids and these
chemicals into,
into the mind.
Like the resonance of the universe changes.
You tune into something that doesn't exist or it doesn't exist without it.
And that that's something that in until we consider that possibility,
it's till we really wrap our heads around what exactly is going on there.
We're ignoring in a pretty profound experience.
We're not even using it as a part of the equation.
We're not even throwing one of the most profound and life altering things that
can happen to a person,
a psychedelic experience,
a real truly profound.
And we're not even introducing it into the conversation.
We're pretending it doesn't exist because we don't want to look.
It's a hallucination and something which your mind makes up and therefore we can
ridicule live.
And the way it,
it's,
it's an important and you know,
kind of like,
and there are people absolutely out there who are absolutely convinced it's not
real.
Sure.
Well again,
you know,
Richard Dawkins,
Dawkins has had no psychedelic experiences and talked about how you maybe you
would consider doing LSD in a clinical setting.
Like,
oh you're,
this is like talking to a child.
Like you're scared and you need to,
you don't need to go do mushrooms,
fish.
You need a,
if Richard Dawkins went and did an Iowasca ceremony or Richard Dawkins went and
smoked DMT,
he would come back with a completely different view on this whole fucking thing.
A brilliant mind and incredible academic.
A guy who is just so good at Boston through the bullshit of religion that,
you know,
especially in the waning years of his existence on this plane and that he was,
he's really cheating as consciousness of not,
not just crossing over at least once,
just to say,
wow,
that's available.
How did I not know that was available?
But also like the,
the,
the attitude of like,
you know,
like I don't need to do this.
So silly.
I know it's,
it's like,
you know,
I know it doesn't exist so I don't need to do,
it's like,
okay,
just to say you haven't done it.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Well they have to justify it because then people will bring it up.
But it's like,
you know,
someone who's never seen combat before and he'd say,
well,
you don't know about war unless you seen combat.
Well,
I don't need,
I don't need to see it.
I know what's going on.
The fuck you do.
How could you possibly understand what,
what happens to a person in the grips of war if you haven't been there?
It's pure speculation.
You don't know.
You know,
there's,
there's many,
many things in this life that are like that.
I think very few are as profound as the psychedelic experience as far as the how
alien it is too.
Normal everyday consciousness.
And I think that has to be considered when you stop and think about the idea of
alien,
Inter interjection,
alien altering of our world.
The idea of the psychedelic experience being a gateway to some other form of
consciousness or some other form of intelligence that has to be considered the
eye,
the eye.
Let me tell you something that happened to me after one of my first DMT
experiences,
I stopped caring about Ufo was completely stopped caring
as a Terence Mckenna.
I remember him and I need a five.
Well that Ufo conference then kind of like,
it's went down the line and you had both Hopkins,
they're in shock filet and they were like physically first and then it came to
him and said like,
I can tell you,
I mean I can't do his accent.
It was very specific.
Like I can tell you like you know I have spoken to these people
don't have to like go around like wondering whether or not you foes are possible
because something is possible.
That's a billion times crazy than that.
The way I was described,
Dmt as mushrooms times a million plus aliens,
like really is like that.
So for someone to,
you know,
to interest me,
it was some flying space disk.
I'd be like,
why don't they just come down here and talk like the DMT guys do?
Cause the DMT
brings you into a completely different dimension.
I,
I just completely got bored with the idea of flying saucers,
you know,
like,
oh look,
it's a little light.
It's spinning around in a circle.
Really?
Is that what that is?
You know,
who knows what the fuck that is?
Who Cares?
I don't even do anything.
If there's aliens and they come here and they just fucking spin around the sky
and then go home,
you know,
it could be like,
this could be like earth.
It's like the high school parking lot.
Like remember when your kids and there's dudes who already graduated and they
come back and do donuts in the parking lot.
Did you,
uh,
did you,
you didn't,
you got an English accent,
right?
What does it,
was it Australian?
What is your accent?
Uh,
I'm originally from Belgium and I speak three languages and assigned like a
Florida and all of them.
So
Ah,
that's what it is.
Then England for about 10 years,
worked in England for about 10 years and I've been partly European,
partly in,
uh,
Los Angeles for the last four years.
When a,
in American high schools,
there's this phenomenon ward that's leaving the nest thing or a lot of guys that
graduated but they still come back to hang out.
They've thought of as losers and they usually have cool cars cause now their
work so that come back and they would do like donuts in the parking lot.
So maybe that's where the aliens are doing.
They're just coming back to show off.
Yeah.
They're only the douchebag.
Aliens come back.
Um,
do you buy into Annie?
But that's why there is a conspiracy because we were covering does up.
Exactly.
Do you buy into any of the like stuff when uh,
you know,
you,
you hear about Ufo is interfering with like launch commands and missiles and the
UFOS,
like cutting power over military bases.
Do you buy into any of that stuff?
Have you ever seen anything that's compelling?
Well,
I know that somebody has written a book about it and I read the book and you
know,
when you take ufs as an unidentified flying objects,
um,
Dan,
it is possible because it doesn't mean it's not earthly.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
and if I was a human power,
um,
I would be interested in,
in an atomic missiles,
I think more so than if I was an alien power.
I mean,
you know,
of course,
if I was nailing okay,
I mean,
making a science,
science fiction scenarios here,
either they say,
okay,
they can blow them to smithereens,
let's do it's,
um,
or,
well,
we have this thing whereby we can pick up this nuclear device anyway in mid
flight and then take it out of there.
But when,
when people tell me weird things happened on a military facility,
um,
involving top secret things and there's a Ufo side it then,
to me that Ufo is probably of terrestrial origins.
Um,
and there's probably a very good reason why,
um,
whoever power it is,
you know,
we would probably blame the Russians first,
but it doesn't necessarily have to be them.
Um,
you know,
kind of like there's a good reason why they are going to keep this secret and
they probably want to pretend.
And I think to a large extent,
the American government has an active promotion of hey,
we are covering up certain things.
Yeah.
Well that whole area 51 thing put a lot of questions into people's minds because
they denied its existence.
What year was it?
[inaudible] 94 or something like that where they want to expand its boundaries.
Yeah.
And then an independent state like,
you know,
like they make a big thing about area 51 and then at the end you see like with
the active participation and help of the departments of,
of,
of the fence.
And you kind of think like any are telling me they didn't read the script.
Yeah.
You're telling me that they're okay with pretending there's a fucking flying
saucer tucked away back there.
Yeah.
What do you believe?
What do you think about Robert Lasar?
Do you know his story?
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
I,
again,
I think he might have seen something which people told him was alien.
Um,
and I think that's a form of protection.
Like,
you know,
if I tell you here is the light,
it's,
it's alien technology.
You're not going to say,
Oh Phillips,
oh,
that must be a cover up thing.
Kind of like,
you know,
um,
people that they're,
they're known instances.
And I think it was bill Moore who found some,
some stuff there in 1953 or 52.
Um,
all of a sudden in America was okay.
Again,
I think we'd Hungary and there was a very important relic across,
off seen Steven or something like that,
which was somewhere,
uh,
displaced after the second world war.
And the American government was going to give it back.
But it was so secretive that nobody knew on this flight.
Um,
what it was.
And the official cargo of what was being transported was described as a Ufo,
uh,
basically crashed saucer,
which was being transported.
They didn't want the people on board to know what it was.
They said it was a crush source or it wasn't.
It was a relic of,
of,
you know,
some st which was being transported back to Hungary.
So,
so they're just freaked people out just to put a stupid story out there for
[inaudible].
Yeah.
And you know,
if you can then convince the soldiers that there's a big cover up,
you're going to probably die if you say that you,
you,
you have,
when you're going to speak out about crashed,
crashed saucers,
the ramp guys are going to be kept quiet.
Yeah.
The Robert was our store.
I'm sorry,
the Robert Lasar story was so compelling because he's so fucking intelligent,
you know,
and what,
he doesn't sound like a liar when he starts talking about the base and stark
about back at reverse engineering the aircraft and you know,
and how they would take them out for test flights or they couldn't exactly
figure out how to work them.
That's fascinating shit.
So it is possible that it was Russian or something.
And then that Robert Lasar was told that it was a,
an alien just because they wouldn't,
didn't want to admit that the Russians had figured out some fucking incredible
shit that we hadn't.
I mean,
you know,
and I agree with you on with our,
I don't think he made this all up.
Um,
he was told something.
The government might have told them the truth,
but I think on balance the government told him a lie.
Hmm.
Look at that Robert Lewis.
Are you just got debunked by Philip Copans?
Well,
I actually think I support him because most people just say he's a liar.
Yeah,
that is,
that's true.
You are supporting them in some sort of a way.
You're,
you're just letting him,
giving him a,
an out like you didn't know that is possible.
Yeah.
I'm seems like Stealth bombers and stuff that,
that we know the government did design that actually looked like aliens and Luke
are you some Ufo?
And as you pointed out,
he's an intelligent guy.
You know,
he,
he came to these conclusions,
he felt that this was alien and I'm more than willing to give him the benefit of
the doubt.
I'm just saying on balance,
our government lies when it tells you this is something alien.
They,
when they tell you that here's the point,
if it's alien,
they would probably tell the guys involved at it was terrestrial.
That's a very good point.
Why would they tell this for I'd motherfucker from the middle of nowhere.
Albuquerque,
New Mexico,
wherever he's from.
Yeah.
We got an alien.
I wonder if they did tell him.
I don't think a story is actually they told them.
I think it's story was that they didn't explain it at all.
They just told him to back engineer it and he did.
He did deuced with his own intelligence that it was,
uh,
an alien craft.
But yeah,
who knows what the fuck they're making out there,
right?
I mean they have this gigantic facility out there,
or at least they did.
I think they've moved things now because so many people are aware of it.
And because of a Google earth,
I believe they,
they believe they've moved stuff to Utah now.
That's the new place where they test out crazy shit.
Well,
I mean again,
I was talking about that was the whole documentary.
And um,
there's some very interesting things.
How,
and actually skeptics in this case are great.
I mean,
there's some great skeptics in the sense that they stick with it.
They've done research for 20 years and that's great.
You know,
w the skeptics I hate are these 24 hit and run guys day.
They see something,
they write something,
they've seen it on Google,
but like,
you know,
like the,
like the likes of called flock when it comes to,
um,
Roswell,
he's got great material in there.
Um,
it can be interpreted in two ways,
but he's got great material and some of the stuff which he's also kind of like,
you know,
confirmed is that you had this tiny cabal of like Jesse Marcel,
the base commander,
which was called,
um,
blonde shard.
They somehow knew the likes of a Barry Goldwater.
And when Goldwater starts talking about,
hey,
can I see what's in hanger,
you know,
18 at at Wright Patterson,
it's a big scam.
It's a scam of these guys who are absolutely convinced that there is alien
material being covered up in,
in Wright Patterson who were trying to get it on the record.
Um,
and who are trying to push the,
the government basically into Kinda like coming up with an answer and the answer
is like fuck off,
you know,
you're not allowed to say this.
Um,
you know,
like Goldwater was basically told he wasn't allowed to to ask such questions.
The government was never going to say anything of the kind hanger 18 didn't
exist and it's like,
okay that's interesting.
These people were working behind the scenes and like the base commander spoke to
gold was trying to push something out there.
Um,
and again,
it's not as such evidence of the fact that something extra terrestrial landed
in,
in Roswell,
but that there are,
that there were more things happening behind the scenes then quite often
[inaudible] are being credited.
There's a clear evidence of conspiracy at Roswell and one of the big pieces
of evidence is the fact that they flew the records out to Wright Patterson air
force base in two separate plans cause they were worried if one of them crashed.
Yeah.
They wanted to make sure that they,
they could not lose this.
Amanda separated this stuff.
Yeah.
And they said it's really light material.
So it wasn't done for weight considerations.
Nope.
Because they claimed that it was material from a weather balloon,
which is nothing.
They can throw that in the back of a plane.
No problem.
Yep.
And I mean,
Kinda like it,
hanging out with it.
Chassis,
Marcellin,
having him talk about his,
his grandfather,
his grandfather was the chief of intelligence for Roswell.
Roswell air force base at that moment in time was the only add field in the
world where there was constantly,
I'm an atomic bomb being sent in the sky.
America wanted to have an atomic presence in the sky as result of that be 52 or
whatever kind of machinery.
Um,
went and landed at Roswell constantly.
There was always one in the sky.
He knew that he had briefed,
um,
people on,
on,
um,
atomic missions of,
of like dropping nuclear bombs.
Uh,
at one point he was one of five people in the world who knew where a certain
bomb was going to be dropped.
He was declared a national hero.
He was,
you know,
when he went into a fort worth and was going to make that announcement,
he was absolutely convinced that he was going to tell the world about the
existence of extraterrestrial beings.
And when you see,
um,
this,
this story through his family,
you see that afterwards he apparently trampled on his,
uh,
metals.
He hated what the American government had him do.
He,
he basically killed thousands of people by sentencing them to death by briefing.
This officer were to drop an atomic bomb.
And at the same level,
he was absolutely convinced that what happened in Roswell was extraterrestrial
and that he somehow had to say on air live that he was an idiot.
Um,
and he,
he hated what the American government made him do.
He trampled on it.
He got out of,
uh,
the government and basically began to repair televisions and radios to occupy
his mind and,
and,
and do something else.
He,
you know,
but in 1947,
he was a guy at the top briefed kind of level.
Whatever he saw shook his mind.
It wasn't wherever Luna,
it's a fascinating thing to me that at all curd,
the majority of these a Ufo and even the coining the term flying saucer,
it all occurred once we started fucking around with nuclear power when we
started fucking around with nuclear bombs.
That's when they seem to start arriving.
That is a,
that is really fascinating to me and if it really did exist and it was just some
sort of an isolated incidence where they came down and said,
all right,
let listen you crazy pink monkeys.
You,
you can't do that.
You can't just go fucking blowing things up with new girl.
You're going to ruin your whole planet.
All right.
Stop Man.
That would be interesting to know.
Well,
and I mean,
you know,
again,
complete speculation yeah.
Of,
yeah.
Our ancestors always say that the goats were there to help us get to somehow
these helpers,
these,
these kind of like,
hey,
we're trying to do it all by ourselves,
but if we run into trouble,
um,
all of a sudden they're kind of go like,
okay,
well have you looked at this,
this problem?
It's like a parent looking at his child and kind of like knowing that four plus
four equals eight,
but after a while you're kind of going like,
okay,
count them on your hands and like,
you know,
you get to eight like that.
Um,
and if this is the case,
if um,
then if we can somehow self destruct completely more than likely to idiocy or
computer failure of pushing,
you know,
whatever buttons,
um,
then you might actually say,
okay,
they,
they would step in there,
they would stop this from happening.
That's a constant theme with people.
Right.
Somehow or another,
the alien overlords are going to step in and stop us at the brink of disaster.
Yeah.
And you know,
there is no evidence for it whatsoever.
Um,
but there is logic to it.
If,
if,
if we do,
we are monitored.
If we,
if we have,
if we are the children and there is an alien intelligence who slightly brighter
Dennis,
who means,
well then they're going to look out for us.
It's like,
so how do you explain Worldstar hip hop.com?
Well,
how are they laying their hands on?
Probably innocent in the larger scheme of things in the larger scheme of things.
In the great scheme of genetics moving forward to our ultimate destiny of being.
You just have chocolate fever.
Could Be Philip Copans listen man,
this book,
I can't wait to read it.
Uh,
I just got it today or otherwise I would have already read it because this is
one of my all time favorite subjects and uh,
this is fucking awesome podcast.
Thank you very much and thank you for having me.
That people want to,
uh,
if the,
the book is called the lost civilization enigma,
I'm sure it's available@amazon.com.
It's available everywhere where books are sold and a z or an ebook version of
it.
Cause I just got one of those Barnes and noble nooks.
There is an ebook version.
There's even an audio book version for people who don't want to read but listen
and they can hear your sultry voice.
They calms him myself,
not you.
Who reads it?
An actual mother fucker.
That's bullshit,
dude.
Why don't you release your own and just fucking put it out as a torrent and ruin
the market.
Easter egg version of you.
Yeah.
How can,
how can you got a great voice,
man?
Why didn't they let you do it?
I know it's the way these things were publishing companies,
it's their idea.
Some Conti stupid ass actor St a bunch of Shitty doesn't even know what he's
talking about.
God damage as reading your work.
They wouldn't let you do it.
Nope.
We need to talk to those people.
What is the public and don't you don't want to get in trouble.
Don't get in trouble.
It's a great book.
It's good.
They give you a deal.
I hope you make some money so folks go out there and buy this shit.
The lost civilization,
enigma by Phillip Copans and Philip copans.com I believe is the website.
The page I lie P and s,
Two p's,
ladies,
gentlemen,
c,
O p.
P.
E.
N.
S.
And you can also find him on Twitter under the same name.
Phillip Copans.
So please follow him and pay attention because this is some fascinating stuff.
Like I said,
I can't wait to get into this.
Thank you very much for a fascinating conversation,
my friend.
If you ever want to come back again,
we've been more than happy to.
We can do this a hundred times.
I'm sure it will be my pleasure to attend.
Thank you.
Please do.
Thanks to Tim for sponsoring our podcast today.
Go to rogan.ting.com and get your freak on you dirty bitches.
Uh,
if you go to Rogan dot Freeman me,
it's a cell phone service and it's 50 bucks off your first ting device and a,
as I said,
they have a wide variety of android phones.
Even have like old school flip phones.
If you one of those dudes,
one of those Dana White type characters.
It doesn't believe in fascinating new shit,
but not me son.
I like the new stuff.
Uh,
thanks to [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
new mood,
shroom,
tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech,
a moon,
all kinds of other shit.
Too much to name.
And we even have Blendtec blenders and Buffalo Jerky bitches.
That's right.
We've got a lot of,
a lot of groovy stuff.
So uh,
go and check that out.
And if you use the code name rogue and you save yourself 10% off any of those
supplements this weekend,
Brian and Tom Segura,
who folks is one of the best fucking comics in the country right now.
Thomson Gora is hot.
If you're,
if you're a fan of good standup comedy,
you're going to want to check out this,
uh,
this,
this weekend shows if you are in the Ohio area,
there is oh,
Ohio Columbus on Thursday.
Is that what it is?
So what does it all on this date?
Army,
sorry,
Dayton on Thursday.
Cincinnati on Friday and Columbus on Saturday.
Uh,
if you're in Cincinnati have used the coupon Code Red Cross,
you can get two for one tickets and uh,
10% of the proceeds go towards the hurricane victims of Oklahoma,
I mean New York.
And he got home.
And if you go to the desk,
squad.tv,
you have all the,
all the links to all the shows and the to buy tickets or you can just go to
Brown paper tickets.com and search for death squad.
And Brian has a bunch of new podcast too that are kicking up in Edwards now.
Just joined us.
I saw that preposterous.
One of my favorite words,
that's name of his beautiful.
And uh,
Kevin Pereira also,
uh,
has a new show called pointless,
which has put out three awesome episodes so far too.
Did you have a third?
Oh,
the third one's coming up.
We're supposed to have a third one a day,
but he has a sinus infection and he's sick at home.
So it was at bobcat.
Yeah,
it was.
It's going to be [inaudible].
He's going to hopefully going to be rescheduled either later this week or we
wish you well brother get better.
What was Kevin has it,
Kevin has it.
Well,
Bobcat,
I want you to be healthy too.
Kevin,
you get better to you.
Fuck.
Go get yourself some Kombucha tea son this weekend.
Joey Diaz and I will be in San Diego at the Bowel Boa theater and we're going to
have a show here Wednesday night at the Ice House.
We just decided like 10 minutes ago to do it.
Um,
so,
uh,
this Wednesday night,
not sure who was going to be,
as soon as I get off this podcast,
we're going to,
I'm going to call don my rare and see if he's going to do it.
Greg Fitzsimmons I would love him to do,
if he's going to be around cause was fucking unbelievable this weekend.
And I know Callan's in town too,
so that's most likely going to be a the lineup or at least part of it.
So,
uh,
we will see you guys tomorrow.
Brian Cowen is our guests.
Uh,
then,
uh,
we have,
Peter Duesberg on Wednesday and I'm going to do something that's the Aids Guy,
right?
Yes.
The AIDS guy.
And we're going to do something Thursday thanks to Hamilton Morris who sent me a
lot of information on the Duisburg and Duesenbergs theories.
So this could be a,
uh,
a fucking awesome week and some of it will do someone on Thursday.
Brian's not going to be here,
but,
uh,
and maybe it'd be me and Joey at my place or something to get Charlie back.
Yeah,
for sure.
All right.
You fucks.
We love you.
We love the shit out Ya.
Thanks everybody that came out to Seattle.
It was awesome.
Yes.
Seattle was like one of the greatest shows I've ever done in my life.
It was,
it was,
it was so warm.
And San Francisco was amazing too.
Uh,
I just,
I,
I love,
uh,
it's better north,
man.
There's something about going up there.
They're smarter up there.
All right.
Asians,
I think t w I had to fucking ruin it.
All right.
We'll see you guys tomorrow.
We love you.
Thanks.
Hm.
Okay.